There we go.
Cool. So,
here's the plan for today.
In fact,
tweet this real quick.
Cool.
Welcome folks.
Plan for today, we're going to start off
with
Oops.
So, let's get uh let's get started for
the day. We're going to do
Let me show where we left off.
Okay, so
we have our initial implementation of
the threaded backend here. Morning Tim.
And we got this to be testable, right?
and lovely. Thank you, Docker.
Just fix that real quick.
All right, the first thing we're going
to do today is we're going to try to
benchmark the current implementation.
Um, we're going to see how fast it is.
We're going to make sure we get
something that is performant.
We make sure it's stable and then
then we will get to move to tiny grad.
That's the only task for today is
knowing that we have a stable
implementation
and then we move on to tiny grad stuff.
Why can't I see our live stream
notifications on X and you're following?
It should always show.
So, it should always show
my icon is live. I think it doesn't
always notify you when I am live. It's
not like YouTube.
Um, it usually will tell you in your
sidebar though if somebody you're
following is live. I don't know if it
always does.
10 mil. We're going to try for 10 mil.
Working now.
Might just take a second. The one really
really annoying thing about X is it
doesn't show you your concurrent view
count.
So I can never actually tell how many
people are watching on X. So I know that
yesterday we peaked at 27 across YouTube
and Twitch, but I have no idea how many
were on X.
Did that just not train at all? Wait, I
swear that I had this training before.
This version trained. I'm almost
positive on uh the other server.
Yeah, I must have not.
Huh.
That's weird.
Well, we'll have to write test anyways.
Let's get a perf check in though.
Yeah, I saw that, dude. I saw that.
That's [ __ ] I don't
I mean to say it's Elon's company is
like it's I think there are a couple
dumbass managers there. Probably the
same [ __ ] that did Yat Yasine
originally.
All right. So we have our test here. Uh
let's add let us add a PF check.
So, let me think the easiest way to do
this
will just be something
Oh, you need to pass the function
handles as well. Um,
what if I
do this?
measured in seconds. Uh, I don't want
the time in seconds.
What's the function you use for perf
checks?
I mean, this is stupid. I should know
this, right?
Wait, am I seriously using time for perf
checks?
Oh, because timeout is in seconds
anyways.
That's not terrible, right?
That's not terrible.
Hey Jess Fu, what are you building? I'm
working on first we're doing some perf
checks like some performance test and
profiling on the vectorzation backend we
uh we did yesterday and then we're going
to do some tiny stuff and if I have time
we'll get to the Ilia podcast. And I
have question. Yes, I stream so that
people can ask questions in chat. Like
how else would you do it?
Wait, how else would you do Oh, time.
Well, you'd use the you wouldn't use a
timing function that's measured in
freaking like integers, right?
It's not bad because it's a they're
quick functions and um you know
realistically it's going to be almost
just the timeout every time anyways
All right, there we go.
Something basic like this.
How many hours do I sleep?
Uh, between 8 and 10 depending
sleep. I slept a lot yesterday. I think
I slept
nine nine and a half hours.
I pretty much usually try to average
like at least eight and a half.
Okay, cool. So, we have this PF number,
which is crap to start with, but that's
a starting point.
Now, first of all, I think that we have
this in
Yeah. So, you see we have this an 0.
We will change this to O2.
And then this one will also go to O2.
Uh we do not have sanitizer of any type
on.
So first let's see what this gives us
just out of the box.
Uh
they compile correctly.
that that's such a small difference, but
okay.
Okay, for now. Now we go to
4096 environments.
Oh wait, I am totally wrong.
Hang on.
Okay, this should be a more reasonable
number.
Okay, 800K.
Now let's go to some real number of
environments.
They have 4096 M's.
And there's 20 million SPS.
Um, now I think we need to do we need to
make sure that this is actually
synchronizing the way we think it is
though.
One GPU.
Yeah.
I mean, we need this number to be in the
tens of millions. Ideally, it should be
able to be faster than that. There's no
reason VEC should be that slow.
In fact, should be able to be
substantially better than tens of
millions, but
you basically want it to be no overhead
since it's async anyways.
Yeah, I think that the actual most
likely setup the actual most likely
setup that we're going to end up using
for this is
this is cool. We no longer need to have
divisible numbers of threads anymore,
right?
Wait, should you expect I'm going to I'm
going to look something up that's very
very stupid. You can all laugh at me for
this. Um,
are the architectural states and some
small buffers.
Okay. So then you should not see
cool. That's fine. So then what we want
is
uh six times five threads
30.
I think you actually can have five. You
actually can have five threads
because I'm doing this for uh the six
wait eight times
or uh we should have this as four by
default. Yeah. So the default
architecture I'll explain why this is a
good idea in a moment.
Thanks [ __ ] for the worker math was
breaking me.
Yeah. So, I mean, it's still going to
affect Perf, but it'll be easier. Tim,
this is why it's dumb. Like, why I just
I hate having to um support like tons of
different backends and things cuz it
just confuses everybody cuz like the
reason that math is there is for a
feature you're not even using.
Okay, so this is 18 mil. So this is the
most likely configuration that we're
going to run. Um 8192 environments with
two buffers gives you 40 96 environments
per buffer.
And
uh they no longer get like split among
threads. The threads are just used to
consume work.
So four threads times six GPUs is 24
cores. But then more importantly, if you
have an 8GPU machine,
8 * 4 is 32. Um, so this fits cleanly
though. I actually don't know how many
8GPU machines only have 32 cores.
We will see.
This is fine for now.
So
uh let's figure out
yeah let's actually figure out what is
thinking here.
So when you call vec uh what is it vex
send or vec receive and vec send
Now we have threads and it so the reason
that the threads are kind of cooler is
because the threads when I had workers I
had to split up tasks across the
workers. Um but when you have threads
it's more like producer consumer. So
it's just the tasks come in and then the
threads grab them and execute them as
they come in.
The only reason that we had
multipprocessing in um uh in Puffer 3 is
just that Python doesn't have threading
pretends to be a real language and
doesn't have proper threading.
They added it in 314, which is still not
the main public version.
Isn't that kind of crazy though? How old
is Python?
late 1980s.
Oh, 1989. Okay. So, you have a
35year-old
language.
Yeah. 35year-old language is just now
getting [ __ ] threading
is insane.
They needed Well, yes, but like
regardless, the fact of the matter is
they didn't have proper threading
and then that language somehow became
the most popular language ever.
kind of an important thing to be
missing.
I'm looking to make sure that this is
not cheating my Perf test somehow.
know what we can do for testing. I know
how we can test this.
just like a cuda mess set right
on it. Uh, it's not that easy, Tim. This
is like a new backend. It's It's no
longer general enough. I mean, it's not
yet general enough. Not no longer. It's
not yet general enough.
Okay, that's my bad for bothering to
check the LM when I can just check the
CUDA docs
mems set and this is not going to be
async
GPU actions
start
val
testing.
So the point of this is I just want to
make sure that this cannot uh cache
anything.
Okay. Well, I mean, this doesn't look to
me like it can cache anything.
I guess we should go just print from the
environment, maybe.
yeah, here's a bunch of random action
garbage getting written.
And it's the same random garbage it
looks like in blocks.
So, it looks to me like this is actually
this is getting uh the data is getting
synced correctly.
Obviously, we're going to do more tests
than that. That was just like the quick
um quick confirmation.
with eight Ms. You're still getting a
few hundredk.
Yeah. So we have 20 mil step per second
ve
appears. Um
we probably want to figure out bandwidth
from that, right?
I'm trying to think what the best way is
going to be
to test this.
Like I suppose um
well it's going to have to be until we
get uh until we get this thing like
bound generally so we can handle a ton
of different M's I think and that's when
it's going to be that we can test this
fully. I would like to see if we're
messing anything up though because
apparently this doesn't train. That
bothers me.
Well, obviously we need to do um send
this comment out this test. It was not
training before this, which is a
problem.
Yeah. So, that's what I want to do,
Carlos. It's just not super
straightforward.
Okay, that is 5 mil SPS,
which I believe that's about what we
expected out of this. That is about the
perf boost we were expecting.
But, uh, that's not helpful if it's
completely broken.
Let's go get the single thread version
of this working. Maybe
Uh, no. We should just do crud stream
sync.
How did Dan train on real Diablo?
Uh presumably he uh he bound it to the
puffer API.
I don't know if he's getting any cool
results on it yet, though. It's cool
that he's gotten it running, but Diablo
1, it seems, is very slow. He said it's
like a few hundred steps per second per
core.
It's actually pretty surprising to me
that it is that slow. I would think it
would be faster.
like it had to run on really old
hardware and that's with the graphics
and everything. You'd think it would get
like a few thousand, right? Like any of
the older games you would think should
at least get a few thousand
when optimizing the RL training loop.
What metrics are used?
Um
well, I mean the ultimate metric is
throughput, I suppose, for what I'm
doing right now. How many steps per
second can we train?
um
like we're looking at things in the
process of that right so I'm looking at
there's overhead from CUDA kernel
launches um there is overhead from host
device synchronization which is what I'm
working on now there's overhead from
vectorization as well um
there's overhead from inefficient
kernels
a lot of stuff
adapted to work. Oh, I see. So, it's
already a Okay. Yeah, I see.
So presumably there's a bunch of
overhead in that repo as well then Tim
cuz Jim is slow as hell.
It's already ready otherwise, isn't it?
It's already ready.
Do you have any feeling how much faster
Puffer can get? Um,
it's tough to say cuz technically you
can get like 100 million step per second
training in raw flops. In practice, it's
very very hard to even get 10. Um, I'm
working on getting 10 for puffer four.
So, puffer three is like two to five
million step per second training most of
the time. And the goal for puffer 4 uh
is 10 mil. So, it's going to be like
roughly 3x perf improvement on average.
That is my target.
I mean, you have to think about like so
why am I doing this, right? Because if I
were to just say that we're not going to
care about models under even 5 million
parameters, uh this gets a lot easier,
right? Like I'm really optimizing this
to work with quite small models. Um
there are a few reasons for this. One is
that like you can actually solve
reasonably hard problems without having
bigger models. um you don't have to go
to multi-node or even multiGPU
infrastructure for a lot of problems
which simplifies things but actually the
thing that I care about the most with
all of this is that if I optimize puffer
lib to this extent and still keep it
simple then basically this tech will
never be lost behind closed doors at
companies uh because like once you can
just run something simply on your GPU at
home
it starts to become like a hobbyist
thing. It starts to like become more
broadly distributed. And then, you know,
RL is never going to just be this
nebulous thing that doesn't make sense
that only a few people do. It's really
just going to be out in the open. And
that's super cool, right? With all the
language model things, like you can't
really It's kind of sucks, right? like
with all the big models like you used to
be able to do RL or not RL you used to
be able to do like deep learning at home
and actually have stuff competitive with
state-of-the-art and that's just not
true anymore in the rest of um ML but it
can still be true in RL that's what
we're doing here
um Google Collab notebooks are total
[ __ ] and the GPUs that they give you on
those are so bad you may as well train
on CPU.
But, you know, if you have any machine
with a GPU in it, you're pretty much
Good.
Well, I am I am making out like that's
what I'm doing here, right? I'm doing it
here because nobody else is doing it.
The truth of the matter is RL is the
hardest branch of AI. Like this stuff is
way like this stuff dayto-day. This is
way harder than anything you'd be doing
on language models unless you're one of
the very few people there who are
actually working on uh like their
distributed infrastructure and
a few of
the kernels I think are probably the
only things that are harder. Like the
actual research work on LM is way easier
than this [ __ ]
And before LLMs got to be the size that
they were, like before the distributed
infrastructure got to be really crazy,
it was just way easier across the board
than RL is because RL like you have to
also optimize. it's non-stationary and
you have distributed environments and
then the data collection from those
environments has to be fast and the
batch sizes for those data for the uh
the data from those environments is
going to be different from the batch
size in training and like their network
differences that you'd want for
inference and training. Like there's a
whole bunch of other stuff that you just
don't even have to think about.
Not to mention that like until the
models get really big, making small
models fast is a lot harder than making
medium-siz models fast.
I done deep learning without Google
Collab.
[Music]
Honestly, an is the better thing to do
is if you need if you like you should
just set up a local dev environment and
just play with [ __ ] on CPU and then when
you want to run actual experiments
like
Oh yeah, there it is. Right. They had
the pricing right there.
29 cents an hour for a 4090.
36 cents an hour for a 5090.
See what I did?
What did I do? Ah, this is what I did.
There we are. So, this should be a
single threaded test.
All right. So, uh, the fact that this is
almost the same speed singlethreaded
means
we're either getting GPU bound
or the synchronization mechanisms are
stupid. One of those two.
So, I think we need to add a a block
size
So the idea between this is uh behind
this is just that we're going to do uh
we're going to make the threads fight
over the environments less. We're going
to give them bigger chunks of work at a
time.
You can do stuff like that. I'll be very
surprised if you get anything that like
if you're doing stuff like that, you
should be testing it on harder problems
essentially.
So, I optimized Puffer to be able to be
fast for pretty small networks because
you can solve some fairly complex
problems with pretty small networks, but
like
it gets harder and harder to optimize
like reasonably good architectures uh as
models get smaller until they get to a
point that they're so small that you
just are doing the whole thing in a
kernel. Um, but then like you kind of
cut yourself out of complex problems.
Do I believe I'm trying to think if I
believe like you could get a humanoid to
walk with like a thousand parameters?
Maybe. Actually,
I'd be super surprised if you could get
like most of the tasks in Puffer though,
especially the harder ones with nets
that size. I think you probably need I
mean we literally we see improved
performance right from
increasing model sizes and it's a pretty
sharp increase you know up to a specific
point like we can't get the same PF with
uh too small of models.
How come smaller is harder? because
there's essentially um when you have
models that are 100 million parameters,
there are tons of different types of
overhead you don't even have to think
about. When the models are 10 million
parameters, the overhead matters a
little bit more. When the models are
100,000 parameters, there's a ton of
different type of overhead you have to
care about a lot.
Where does that plateau?
And go run a sweep, right? go run a
hyperprem sweep on most of the
environments with a 32 hidden dimension
and then go do the same thing with 128.
Even go ahead and wall clock match them
or flop match them if you want. You'll
see that they don't match in um in Perf.
Like you just need above a certain
number of parameters to learn.
I forgot to do this totally, didn't I?
Let's do like eight
right. This is exactly what we were
expecting, right?
You see this is now substantially faster
because they're fighting way way less
over um chunks of work. So now if I do
like 64 or something
one and let's see 256
just see what the uh the drop off point
is.
uh double buffering has already been in
puffer. Okay, cool. So, you don't really
get anything from going up to this much.
Leave it at 256.
This is buffered. Um,
this is not the same double buffering.
So, double buffering usually is like,
you know, you grab the first chunk of
M's and then you do the second chunk of
M's where the obs are processing for the
first chunk. So, what we're doing is
we're extending buffering to include the
hooded device transfers. Um, so the obs
are going to be ready for you waiting
already on GPU, not on CPU. And that's a
major uh that is a major
possible improvement.
Actually, we need to now run this with
one thread, not zero.
13 mil H.
That is not
Can we think about why that doesn't
scale perfectly?
Let's just set this to one buffer for
now
to like decomplicate
Okay, so we get 10 million with one
thread.
take some of the more complex ones in uh
in Puffer. Man,
2048's been pretty good. We just have
Okay, look at that. So, we have four
threads and we only get 2x perf. That's
bad.
Oh, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Hang on. It's not necessarily bad
because we can be getting cuda bound,
right?
I'm trying to think how we test that.
I think we just like do like this maybe.
Maybe it's Hang on. Maybe we don't have
that many cores free.
I mean, you can definitely try it. Like
the thing that you would want to use is
the uh the end vectorzation.
Like the most important thing for gen is
uh the environment vectorization.
Honestly, I don't even know if you need
if you need GPUs. Like for naive
genetics, you don't even need GPUs.
Okay, interesting. So, why is this
slower with 12 threads?
That seems bad, right?
I mean, these M should be basically done
instantly.
times
12.
Oh, you know the other thing that we can
do to check this
Num M's is 16k.
Really?
16ks
kernels.
Yeah, that's the issue when you're at
those speeds. It's like, well, the M's
have to be on the GPU and like you can't
do the M's on the GPU. You're like,
you're limiting yourself to stupid
tasks.
Okay, so it seems like we're capped at
million SPS.
it's annoying because I can't isolate
the environment versus the
I mean, I guess what I can do here,
let's do something.
If I do 16
four
What other goals do you have? So, it's
the
uh the new low-level back end hitting 10
million steps per second with the new
architecture
uh and then constellation. So, I guess
if you want to lump them together, it's
like the high throughput high throughput
and then constellation. So, it's going
to be a combination of the we're going
to release the most ludicrously high
performance RL toolkit out there and
then we're also going to release the
most uh ludicrously oversized
data set of or like
yeah I guess data set of uh completed
and tuned hyperparameters
tuned experiments for RL. We're gonna
have very large scale visualization of
RL and then just stupidly fast training.
But the OBS space of Breakout, isn't it
like isn't this 12 gigs per second
actually?
Wait,
it's 119 floats
times 4.
Yeah. Oh, that's 14 gigs a second.
Oh, this gets faster as well. That's
cool.
Okay. So, gen 4.
Ah.
Huh.
Oh, you know, I wonder if this is the
thing.
I have a theory here.
Hang on. I'm just checking some speeds
here.
Hello, welcome.
Paris, I honestly I don't even know what
I can do with that.
on one hand we're not exactly
computebound with what we're doing now.
On the other hand like
there is fundamentally value um to
making our stuff faster, right? like
there's a huge difference and there is a
huge difference in what I'm going to be
able to do with Puffer uh if it runs on
32 GPUs or if it runs on one GPU
regardless of whether I have unlimited
access to GPUs. Does that make sense?
I mean, it's kind of like the difference
of like, well, you know, why do you need
to have like why do personal computers
need to be able to run stuff, right? We
can run them on like these mainframes
and we have lots of them.
And like most of the stuff that I could
scale is not currently GPUbound either.
It's like CPUbound. Like I would love to
just scale the crap out of Net Hack and
see what happens. I'd love to run full
sweeps on Dota, right? To see like you
know what is like what can we like get
full full insights on Dota uh with RL
like stuff like that you could do. But
you're mostly you're infrared and CPU
bound. you're not GPU bound in either of
those.
Like realistically,
I can absolutely afford to rent the GPU
time um to do like those types of
experiments on Dota, but that's not the
bottleneck.
I just want to check the uh the
bandwidth basically of these machines. I
want to see if this is on PCIe4.
Yeah. You see? So this actually is gen
five.
I want to run I want to rerun this Perf
check.
Uh, it's going well so far. Peru, I
think I got some bugs still, but I have
We're starting to get reasonable speeds.
performance here is
31.
So this is not actually faster
really.
That's a little odd to me. I was
expecting this to just be double the
speed.
Well,
I think that's fair enough for now.
Let's see if we can figure out why uh
this thing stopped training and
then we can move on to tiny grad stuff
for the day
if I can at least get this to train
correctly.
So, uh let me show you Peru the latest
thing. So, Peru is the guy who wrote the
initial multi-thread back end. I've done
a lot of stuff with it since. Um,
so here's the latest architecture.
You can ignore all these stupid prints
and stuff that I was uh testing things
in. So you have your same Cthread step
from before. You're going to notice
there are three indices now. So there's
the work index, there's the completed
index, and then there's the end index.
Um, so you wake up the
yeah, you wake up the worker
and
thing I added here. You're going to
fetch the work index.
You check it versus the end index. Now,
because uh you get assigned like a
specific amount of work to do, you check
versus this this end index. You're going
to do a block of steps, not just one
step. This is very important for Perf.
you basically have everything fighting
over the atomics otherwise.
Um
and then here
this is adding to completed. So once
you've completed these tasks you mark
them as done.
This is important because it tells the
main thread when all the jobs are done.
And then this thing is overflow
protection which this is needed because
um you can count past the end and when
you are orchestrating task the way this
is you need to not count past the end.
And then you have this manager thread.
This is the new thing. This is not the
main thread. This is a new manager
thread.
Obviously I'm going to clean up all
these names and all this like comments
and garbage um and all this spacing.
But here
so there are two chunks to this. So this
is actions ready on GPU and then you and
the stream is synced then the actions
are ready on the CPU. So you check when
the actions have been transferred to CPU
and that is when you broadcast to the
workers that they have work and you say
that you have a block of new work block
size.
And then the other thing that this
manager thread does is it checks when
uh it checks when completed is greater
than block size plus thread plus art
index. So what this is is this is saying
that those workers have finished a block
of work. So when the workers have
finished a block of work, it's going to
initiate an asynchronous mem copy
uh of the observations terminals rewards
back to the uh to the GPU.
So essentially what I've done to your
stuff, so one I added the double
buffering and that wasn't that bad, but
then I also I made it so that the uh the
async also includes the CUDA transfers.
So not only are going to have
observations ready for you, you're going
to have them ready for you on the GPU.
And likewise, when you hit send, you
don't have to wait for the actions to go
to the CPU. That's also done async.
So this should basically let you get
maximum possible throughput.
Uh and yeah, we've tested this up to
up to 30 million
steps per second vec, which is 14
gigabytes
on the test task.
I don't have clean comparisons yet.
Peru. Um, I did notice though, so when I
run this, I immediately doubled the
speed of training up to like 5 mil from
the initial baseline. So I think it's a
few million steps per second at least.
But I have something broken because it
it was not breaking training for a while
and then I did something that broke
training.
Oh yeah, and for whoever said neural MMO
for a million years,
this is I think 40,000 years worth of
data that we have from neural MMO right
here. So not a million, but we've got
40,000 years.
This is actually kind of funny that
we're able to get a score of close to
seven with this. This is like a totally
garbage network.
I have to come up with some more
experiments to run on this.
Actually, if Kung swings by, I'm going
to ask him if he can set up if he wants
to test uh his new sweeps with like
10 billion step runs on neural MMO. That
would be cool. Or 100 billion step runs.
Yeah, you probably need you probably
literally need a 100red billion steps to
sweep MMO.
Okay, so yeah, Peru, thank you very much
for the initial on this and I will I'll
make sure that this is not a mess by the
time I ship it. Honestly, I think all
these indents and stuff being weird was
just because I was deving on the tiny
box and like BIM didn't have tab expand
or something set. And then there's some
names that need to be cleaned up. There
are a couple other things I was
debugging with race conditions, but this
whole thing is only going to end up
being a couple hundred lines of code.
And as you can see, like this is
if we can buffer all that stuff, it'll
be nice.
Still training after that long. That's
the point though, right? That's why
neural MMO is good. It's because it
continues to make progress for that
long, right? That's what makes it an
interesting environment.
Eventually, I think what's going to
happen though is like we're going to
come up with something that just solves
it and like saturates way faster and
then it's going to stop being an
interesting environment. It's going to
be solved and we're going to have to
make neural MMO 4.
Hey, talk.
C rapper lib retro.
What? Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. 32
threads. Hold on, hold on. Lib
32 threads. Aar, I want that
immediately.
or are you keeping this for yourself?
How the hell did you get
Okay, I want to talk immediately.
How the hell did you get Pokemon Red to
300K, dude? We timed
lib retro clone lib z retro. Wait wait
wait. How did you get the emulator that
fast? We tried like mgba. We tried pi
boy.
Is it that much faster or is it the fact
that you're not ren Wait. Are you
rendering? You're getting 300k frames or
300k steps.
Pump time everything.
Yeah, but like emulators are actually
that is a contested space, dude. That is
not somewhere I would expect it to be.
No. Headless. Okay.
Rendering cuts it in h only half.
Oh, we don't even need it that big,
huh?
you can come help set like one of the
best results in the field with this.
Like really really easily.
Actually, several of the best results in
the field with this,
dude.
What in the hell?
Oh, I will gladly add zigbinds for
something like this.
Fully GPU res. Would that wait,
would that work?
Would you like to chat on stream by the
way? I'd be happy to jump in a call with
you right now on the stream
Well, like the main thing that was
limiting Pokemon Red. So, why was
Pokemon Red such a hard project? Like,
yes, it's a hard environment
of the wife and selling hanger. Okay,
that's totally fine, dude. I understand.
But like, holy crap.
But I wouldn't expect this to be
possible because So, the logic here is
that emulators are a pretty contested
space, right? It's like um there are
like several emulator projects and speed
is pretty contested.
And Wasome. Oh, of course. But that's
Oh, that's so good.
is it?
Wait, so is itund
125 with rendering?
It doesn't have to render for reference.
Like we can still make use of this, I
think, regardless.
Also, how on earth would this work on
GPU? Like would it not be slower?
I mean, Pokemon is about as branchy as
it gets, right?
No, I added audio and rendering because
I'm a nerd. Well, I mean, training on
frames is not terrible. Like,
it's all pure Zigg comp time.
What do you mean it's all pure Zigg comp
time?
What is done compile time that was not
done before? at compile time.
All the branching
just one big unrolled. Wait, what
is that not like massive?
Wait, how
Jeez,
I'll go I'll start reading some Zig code
for that.
Where is big file?
Oh, these are small files. Where's big
file?
Oh, yeah. So this, by the way, this is
when I say that we're doing like stupid
baby engineering in Puffer and it's
still fast. This is what I mean. Like
we're literally we're not doing any SIMD
and Puffer is still as fast as it is.
That's what you can do actually fast.
Okay. So, how is this entire thing
unrolled? Compile time.
140 mil
final jump table. Yeah, but 140 mil SPS
on cartpole is nowhere near as
impressive as this. Like we get I think
we get what is it like 60 or 80 mil?
Something like that
instead of function pointers and trash.
The final jump table is just a switch.
Huh?
Yes, I'll talk. But like for context, I
can't even tell you how many people will
like show me some I made very simple
thing fast in a way that like clearly is
not going to work on anything else.
Right? So there is a huge distinction in
my mind between like I made simple thing
fast and I made thing fast in a way that
actually is going to work for problems
we care about.
So most researchers they basically go oh
we can't make anything that we care
about fast. We're going to just have
everything be slow. A lot of Perf
engineers that don't understand RL will
like make stuff fast in a way that
doesn't actually help. But then getting
both of those at the same time is very
rare.
Hit a wall with lib retro.
Uh I will 100% spot compute for this
dude.
Like I think
32 cores we should be able to get it
training at near that speed.
Why is a Zig Game Boy emulator so
important? Because if we are able to run
like any Game Boy game on this at over a
100,000 steps per second, then we can
use them for research. The problem is if
is the existing runs want run at like a
few thousand steps per second, which is
too slow for research. So this basically
makes all of our compute worth an order
of magnitude more.
It's been less than 24 hours of day.
What?
24 hours of dev. How the hell did you
write 3500 lines of code in 24 hours?
Do you believe I wrote zero code by
hand?
If you wrote zero code by hand and this
is correct, then I will be incredibly
impressed. If you wrote zero code by
hand and this ends up being completely
stupid, then
that will be another story.
yeah see I don't know enough about CPU
or uh Not even CPU like old
architectures.
I mean, I want to see at least a couple
training runs out of this or at least a
binding so we can play with it first.
I mean, the I'm a little suspicious by
the fact that you gave it targets that
are obviously impossible.
They aren't impossible.
I'm pretty sure there aren't enough
flops in the CPU for this.
Okay, you wrote frames.
You have five mil single thread.
Would let me think. Would I believe
that?
through an emulator.
I don't know if I would believe that
You write a 1500 line emulator that hits
5 mil. I don't know if I would believe
that's possible.
I'd be pretty damn surprised if that's
actually even physically possible.
Isn't this the same guy who did Pokemon
with Q-learning? Uh, that's Peter
Whitten.
Liberty.
Oh, no. That's not Q Learning. He did.
He was using PPL.
Like the main Pokemon Red project is
Peter Whitten.
If you get one game in here, like
actually training at 100k
or from this like it looks like 200k.
Wait, there's no way that it only gets
cut in half as well with
with rendering, right? No way.
we do like 24 frame skip in Pokemon.
Would that maybe
Well, you can't frame skip the state
updates. The only thing you can do is if
you wanted to train on pixels, you would
do like 24 frame skip
for Pokemon at least. The 20 20 every
24th state you render. There.
I mean, you should literally be able to
hook this up to the um the Pokemon Red
repo, right?
Could you just swap?
Can you Is it Can you just swap this
with the like as the back end with Pi
Boy?
Wait, you get 22K per thread and then
the threading is just bad.
What?
Wait, AMD Ryzen 9. What do you have with
the AMD Ryzen 9 that even has 32 cores?
Oh, 32 threads.
I don't The [ __ ] AI keeps changing
that.
Oh, what
what CPU is this tested on?
So, you tested on this and you got
11x speed up.
I think 16x is about what you expect out
of this CPU with good threading.
So, actually, this would be way faster
on one of our CPUs
freaking laptop. Okay.
So yeah, this would be like 500k plus.
Okay. Well, all right. Look, as always,
I am incredibly suspicious of AI
workflows in general. Uh I have
literally never seen this work,
but this does seem good. and I've seen
you do other stuff. Uh if you get
anything remotely in this ballpark like
hooked up to puffer and training, this
would be like a massive massive thing
for AI because we would be able to have
access to real like tens of hour long
games training at hundreds of thousands
of steps per second, which is like one
gen behind our fast M, but like that's
still really really solid. and we can
use those for a ton of research. Um,
yeah,
I will be sending a lot of things your
way if this is actually correct. And I
will probably have to go re-evaluate a
bunch of stuff about LLMs.
like if you get us a demo of like here's
Pokemon Red training at 100,000 plus SPS
like
Yeah.
not a vibe coder. Dude, if you said you
wrote literally zero code,
are we using like are we in the same
reality here? Because any of the any of
like I've tested all the models at least
at some point and they are all eating
glue.
Like I can never even get models to
output a 30line chunk of code that is
not dog [ __ ] for anything remotely
sophisticated ever.
It's literally a meme in here.
But I think I'm going I'm I will reserve
judgment until we see that demo.
And the same goes for you FBR. Like I
will believe cuz I know you use LLMs a
lot. Like I'll believe it when I get an
actually like an actually really
impressive PR out of it for a thing that
fully works.
particularly if you're getting anything
remotely compact out of
Wait.
Okay. Yeah, you do have this.
Compiler is not going to let you make
any mistake.
You can absolutely have bugs.
and freaking Zigg
Liberty, I don't do 80% of the code with
LLMs, though.
Unless you're considering like the
oneline autocomplete I have. That is
such a stupid model that that's like
that's basically just an LSP at that
point. It's like a slightly better LSP.
And like I intentionally have that
stupid model as well.
yeah,
I uh
yeah, let's get get a PR on this. If we
can if you actually end up getting like
the Pokemon demo running at 100K and we
can train the model on that. Um
that will change a lot of stuff with
Puffer and we will have to talk about
professional stuff as well because I
will have some offers for you.
But I'm going to want to see it first
cuz I don't know how the hell I honestly
I don't know how the hell you got this
out of Claude at all.
I'm running Zigg on the CPU. What do you
mean you're running Zigg on the CPU
with 80% of the standard library? Wait,
what do you mean by that?
Zigg compiled to CUDA.
Wait. Compiled to CUDA PTX and running.
Did you mean to say running it on the
GPU?
I still don't understand how this thing
is one giant table.
How big is that table?
How big is the um the switch table for
this thing?
What the hell does that even make sense?
JSON decode.
Well, but like so the question I have is
like how fast can you get this entire
thing on I would think that this thing
would just be slow on GPU because of
branching
like the architecture I have I'm working
on now is for CPU vectorization
with buffered transfers
uh to and from CUDA. So, we're
exploiting the fact that there's going
to be some model uh model inference time
and we're going to buffer the transfers
while you're doing model inference for
the next batch.
So, the idea there is that we should be
able to get first of all pretty close to
PCIe speeds with decent batches and uh
then that time actually is going to get
amortized by the inference time anyways.
Yeah, but we're interle more than we're
interle even in puffer 3, right? Because
in puffer 3, we were interle time, but
now in puffer 4, we're also interle
device and device host transfer for obs
and actions. So it's mostly for obs.
My understanding was that like you
shouldn't be able to get arbitrary stuff
like this to just run fast.
Cudigraphs and streams. Um, no
cudigraphs yet. That is to be
determined. I actually want to mess
around with tiny uh tiny a little bit
first because they have some interesting
stuff for overhead. Uh, streams. Yeah,
each buffer has its own stream, but
that's not for the network. That's for
OBS and action transfers.
Yeah, I'm going to I think I'm going to
have to like Jeez,
if this thing freaking works, Man,
Trying to think how the [ __ ] this could
be.
Literally, how the hell could that be
faster?
Like just writing in Zigg is not enough.
This is not a giant switch. This is a
fairly small switch.
No function pointer [ __ ] This is
function pointer [ __ ] isn't it?
Oh, I guess the compiler is going to
unroll it. Yeah.
No way. Saving one function call though.
Did it not have What was the What was
the uh frame?
37 395.
Yeah. 10. Wait, no.
This is 32 threads.
One thread.
22k.
But wait, is this single core PF?
It is, isn't it?
I see.
I didn't account for the frame skip in
that
by 24 and you only get 10k.
Ah,
Well, you wrote the spec to 5 million,
so
point stands.
If you get 100k training,
be very impressed.
But I'm pretty sure
when you actually wait, when you equate
these numbers, these are the same
numbers.
It's the fact that training
this ends up getting cut by like 24 by
frame skip.
I'm more convinced that this is possible
now. But it's possible because actually
I think this is the same PF
Well, we will see if you can get this to
be faster.
You don't have to match exactly, but I
think the easiest thing to do would be
to like just show that you can train the
uh the Pokemon network faster.
Admittedly, that's a giant codebase at
this point,
I'm pretty sure that when you equate
those, they actually the Perf numbers
match between these two.
because it's 1k per core.
Yeah.
Well, if you do manage to get this to be
way faster to that 5 million FPS, which
then goes down to 200k with a reasonable
frame skip
or even if you get like 2.5 mil, if you
get if you get 100k training with the
frame skip already applied, then um then
you have something crazy.
I will be very very surprised though.
But at the actually the current number
actually does match roughly what you
would expect.
I got to get back to this vectorization
and I will see what you cook up
throughout the rest of the day.
Let me go get a refill on my coffee. I
will be right back.
salvageable from wait hang on what are
all these questions hi I'm doing
research on multi-objective RL a couple
months ago disco
multi-objective RL and puffer wrapping
mode gymnasium environments and puff ram
managed to do pretty easily puffer
doesn't really work with multiple
rewards yes it doesn't work out of the
box with multiple rewards
You can tune any combination of them
that you would like. Uh works by
training a policy that takes this input
the observation plus a ve a weight
vector to scalarize the reward. You
would just cheat the you would just
cheat the weight vector into the
observation.
Wait, scalarize the reward. Observation
plus a weight vector to scalarize the
reward takes
as input to scalarize the reward. Oh.
Um, Paul, you would, all you would do,
that's actually super easy. You can use
all of Puffer Lib just fine.
Literally, all you have to do is take
your multiobjective reward, like your
multicomponent reward, and cheat it into
the observation space. You have your
OBS. Let's say your reward has five
components. Last five uh last five spots
of the obs are going to be last five
entries are going to be the reward. And
then you just when you're training you
just split out the observations. Just
hack the puffer.py file to split out
those obs and then use it for your
algorithm. Done. Easy.
And if it's just if it's purely inside
of the network, then it's even easier.
It's cold in here. Let me get myself
wrapped up.
Is absolutely freezing in here. And
unfortunately, that's all I need it to
be so I can think straight.
auto talk, if you're still here, I will
be uh I will be monitoring progress on
this.
There will be a huge huge difference in
whether this the project ends up being a
port of eyeball to ZIG that is roughly
the same speed or if it ends up being
like architecturally different and way
faster.
If you get something that is
architecturally way different and faster
and you've been writing all your code
with code with claude, I will be
completely and utterly shocked.
Oh, wait. This is the uh the Runescape,
dude.
Are you in dev? Where? Where did you do?
Wait, where's the uh
bird?
Wait, this is not you as well, right?
I'm everywhere. Okay, this is somebody
else. And where were you posting stuff?
Uh, so if I want to adjust weights
during the training process, I should
control that from the end. No, you can
keep the weights as part of the network,
man. That's no problem. You just have to
cheat the like you can do that wherever
you want. The only thing you need to do
is expose the rewards to the obs and
then just split them off. And then like
that's how you basically anything that
you want to communicate from the
environment to the main process, just
stick it into the observations instead
of trying to hack Puffer to add an
additional communication channel. Just
stick it in the observations.
Hey Jess.
Didn't post. Oh, okay. I thought you
said that you posted something.
it's still cool though to see like
a new emulator in Zigg in 24 hours is
pretty wild. But that is something like
okay I will believe that an experienced
dev who has actually written a bunch of
code by hand and is now like just doing
stuff with like I I would believe that
if you hit 5 mil or even like if you hit
2 mil sp uh SPS I will be shocked and
that will be a whole another story.
The thing that I had forgotten is I'd
forgot to account for frame skip, right?
So 200k,
240k, then 24 frame skip. You're down to
10k, which is roughly what you can get
with um with pi boy
fintech CTO.
It's cool that you do um this number of
projects then when you uh you have other
stuff to do. I mean, this is my
full-time, right?
I do some client work as well that I
don't stream around Puffer,
but I spend pretty much as much of my
time as I possibly can on Puffer itself.
recovering from a disco dislocated knee.
That sucks. I'm sorry to hear that. That
actually sucks.
As I've gotten more and more in shape, I
like I value my ability to train so
highly that like I basically don't do
anything where I could possibly get hurt
anymore
because I go batshit insane if I can't
train.
Yesterday was intended to be a onem PR,
but I think I tied um I think I tied it.
Okay, back to this. We were testing and
bindings
all my life from computer home to roost.
Well, that's how tech goes. I've uh
you know I've traded very very many
things to be able to put in the amount
of time I have with this. And
I mean it's ultimately so cool though
that I can now like shape an whole area
of science
stuff I do.
I will say I was out of shape. Um,
I think I started like really trying to
train seriously again four or five years
ago only.
I think 5 years ago.
And I didn't start running until I think
three years ago.
Been the best thing I've done though by
far.
Buffer driver when
uh I haven't synced it in a while, Finn,
because I got a new phone and I have to
like actually set it up on that. I have
all the data on my watch. I got to I'll
check all the PRs at some point. I said
a bunch of them. Uh Jess, the creatine
experiment was a complete and utter
failure. Uh no, that does not work for
me at all. It just kills my stomach, any
form of it.
We will try again once I have made other
adjustments.
Okay.
Uh this test
is going to be
One buffer
256 block size
threads.
Wait, is this puffer
on the right one here? Yes. Yes, I'm on
the right one.
Thanks for the pointers and insights. So
explore direction of having rewards
vector card obs. I think that's going to
be the easiest thing for you because
then you can just slice the obs, right?
And you can do whatever you want from
there. Moral algorithm uses purto
dominance to keep track of the set of
weights that results in prito optimal
keep track of the set of weights.
Um well if you think of it as just
pufferell as the whole algorithm in one
file like
I like so if you have to add a thing
that does an archive over the policy
then you're going to have to add some
additional logic over it right
throughout training kind of the same way
that uh the sweeps does
but like puffer if you look at that file
it's maybe 400 lines of actual training
logic and then a whole bunch of
performance uh performance benchmarking
and logging and stuff. So like if you
think of only having 400 lines of
algorithm to hack,
the only thing that it's more the only
thing simpler than puffer to hack is
clean RL and clean RL is slow, right?
Like Puffer was meant to be fast clean
RL while keeping as much of the
simplicity as possible.
You have a degree in what? Um,
bachelor's in CS from Stanford, PhD in
EECS from MIT. If you care about the
formals,
I mean, I've pretty much just been doing
AI the whole time for both of them,
though. Like, the degrees aren't
actually as specific as the thing that
you're doing.
Oh.
Uh, create M's.
Yeah, I just I messed this up,
right? So, this is supposed to be
M's threads,
I mean I generally I try not to flex the
credentials. Uh except when you have
somebody that like only cares about the
classic credentials,
which unfortunately does happen
occasionally,
Zig is so hardware optimized. Would
Puffer work better if you were written
in Zigg?
See that question? Okay, that's a dumb
question. Let me explain why that's a
dumb question.
Zigg is not faster than C.
Right. Zigg is not faster than C. What
does it mean for our language to be
hardware optimized? Like you can say
that about I guess Python versus
something lower level because Python
doesn't compile either it doesn't
compile to machine code directly. it
goes through an interpreter
like okay but basically anything like
Rust dig C++ C they can all be the same
speed
and all the environments in Puffer are
written in C
uh the training is PyTorch and yes
there's some Python overhead which is
what I'm dealing with with Puffer 4
and there is like language overhead but
there are many other sources of overhead
that are completely independent of the
language as well.
Zig is faster than C in most situations.
The current benchmark that you have is
uh is currently equal to pi boy which is
Syon.
Did you see this?
So, so far if you're going to make that
claim,
where is it?
I've not seen any benchmarks that give
like your compiler would have to be
better.
But don't rust people say the same and
they're always wrong.
Where was the link to your thing?
Uh,
big. It's not going to be indexed yet,
right?
Oh, actually, there are a couple of
these.
Um, but probably nowhere near as good.
Rust people do and they are.
Yeah, Rust is usually slower, right?
Cuz like the way that you make Rust fast
is you either write unsafe Rust or you
be very very careful.
Zig, I will believe gets you like sea
speed most of the time.
Yeah,
I don't see what the hell zig like Okay,
if Zig is faster than C. What is it?
Come like what is it doing that is that
C is not doing
I don't think you write your same like
basic normal code and see outputs
faster.
Compile time versus runtime.
What What does that mean?
Like what can the Zig compiler optimize
that the C compiler can't,
As far as I'm aware, Zigg doesn't change
your programming model fundamentally,
but I don't see what other optimizations
the compiler would be able to introduce
that your C compiler can't.
Okay, but like
your normal Zig code looks pretty
similar to your normal C code, doesn't
it?
Well, if you're saying it's faster, like
being faster would mean that there is an
appreciable difference if you just like
write the same program the way that you
normally would in either language.
see with LMV LLVM annotations.
Where do the annotations come in?
I didn't see anything in the source that
like looked all that fundamentally
different.
Like honestly, Zigg looks like to me it
looks just like what C++ should have
been.
I'll give it that.
I will admit I don't know about like
what safety stuff the Zig compiler
enforces. I know it's nowhere near as
heavy as Rust.
Don't really use LMS to help you.
Yeah, that is the usual discussion. I do
not find them helpful
other than for mostly for fuzzy docs and
fuzzy LSP.
I don't find them helpful for for
thinking, let's say.
I was working on this thing and then we
got I got like completely distracted by
um the emulator which is a cool project.
I will wait on uh I mean hey ultimately
if he makes it substantially faster than
pi boy I will be very impressed.
TypeScript is Java with type
annotations.
Is TypeScript faster or isn't it
literally slower?
I thought TypeScript is literally slower
like Python's like Python's types. If
you enforce Python's types, it literally
makes the language slower, which is a
joke, right?
Uh this inst
buffers
block size.
Oh, that that's actually fine. Buffers.
I forgot one thing. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
There should be two
what the possibilities with Zigg. So,
um, Kinvert, it's still a awesome
project, but, um, the thing that I had
not been factoring in was the frame
skip. So, so far the reported single
thread uh, Perf number from Otar matches
Pi Boy's single thread number. So, I'm
waiting to see if he gets it to be way
faster. I've dropped it in poker gem.
Oh, okay. Um, let me think. How do we
I can get a box for that.
Invert, you got a spare box for this?
We can do uh we could run this on that.
Okay. Dropped it into Poke Gem on
GitHub. Yeah. Get it synced up and like
Kvert if you want like
I'd like to see a run of Pokemon with
it. So that'll be the correctness check
and then I'll talk it'll be uh up to you
to see
if you can get the Perf numbers cuz like
Yeah. The problem with The problem is if
you don't include frame skip in the Perf
numbers, right? Like you're never going
to train,
you're almost never going to train 60
FPS.
Like unless you're doing precise
control,
but like Pokemon, you press a button and
like the most amount of time, the
minimum increment of time that matters
in that game is like, I don't know, 20
30 frames.
Did you get him that paperwork thing
yet?
Uh, no. I got just the I got just the
paperwork thing for chess.
Don't have frame skipping at all. I
assumed headless. Well, frame skipping
is just like
you have a render function, right? So,
it's literally you just call render
every 24 frames if you wanted to do
that.
Okay. Uh, is something massively broken
here? I believe there is, right?
Yeah, there's something massively
broken.
M because this is zero.
Yeah, zero
threads.
Okay, then I did fundamentally break
something, right?
What are you using to live stream this?
Restream.
Yeah, once it gets like on the public
GitHub and we can look at stuff.
convert. I'll get him I'll get him on it
if he's going to do stuff around here.
like this sounds like it's more of um
like a hobby like slashcool thing,
right? Like if you're a fint if you are
a fintech CTO, you're not going to be
interested in like professional stuff,
I'd assume.
holding if the price is right.
Uh the price is typically 50% of
whatever we're charging clients
as we do it's like contracted work with
uh four companies building custom sims
and stuff.
Yeah. So, with how I'm running Puffer at
the moment, it's just dramatically
easier to do everything via contracting
like that
because it lets me just give people a
good percentage of
whatever we're making without having to
like set aside more for
uh to set aside more for risk and stuff
like that.
Compile TypeScript get optimized
JavaScript.
Um I that seems possible. Son of
Liberty. Is that actually what happens?
Because in Python when you add types you
actually make it slower if you enforce
them.
I don't actually know if JavaScript gets
faster with types
or not.
Like with Python if you write Sython
instead right then it gets faster
because it compiles it down to C using
the types.
But if you just use the naive type
system and then you use something to
enforce them, you don't get any perf
benefits and you have the overhead of
enforcing them.
But like the thing is both C and zig are
typed already. So I don't know what
additional annotations you'd be writing
in your code or that the language would
be enforcing to let you get any
optimizations. Right? That was the point
from before.
I'd have to see some example of that.
Like I don't
like you can technically do that as
well. Right. There's like unroll and
stuff. Sure.
At splat. Oh, okay. I see. I see.
Does that do you not have like pragma
unroll and stuff?
That's an area I actually I really don't
know very much about um in C because we
never have to optimize to that extent,
right? We just write like brain deadad
simple C with uh without doing dynamic
memory allocations everywhere and
you are already fast enough in almost
all cases before you even have to do
anything else.
You can just use inline. Yeah, we inline
um you know we inline some small
function. Sure.
Line does. Yeah.
I mean, there are obviously way more
things you could annotate. So, yeah, I
could see that.
But that doesn't seem to me like, oh,
the language is faster, right? That
seems like if you're using if you are
using specific annotations because you
have low-level knowledge of what the
compiler should be doing.
like in the same vein as unrolling loops
and stuff, right?
Annotations are part of the language
like pragma.
If it doesn't, that does seem like a
good thing to have.
file time is literally code
running.
Use it to generate more literally see
code running at build.
Use it to run All right, more zigros
aren't the
macros aren't the I agree that the macro
um
the way macros work is kind of jank.
Yeah, I mean it seems like Zigg has some
nice things. I've already said, right?
Like it seems like way way better than
C++.
Like what C++ could have been for sure.
Yeah, I mean there are places where you
want Perf optimizations and there are
places where it doesn't matter, right?
Your innermost loop of whatever it is
you're running a billion times, you want
to be very well optimized.
I'll get to that level of optimization,
I'm sure, like relatively soon in sim uh
sim development
and I'll see how it feels in C versus
other in other places.
Oh, I actually how are Zig's build
times?
That is one of my favorite things about
C is just everything builds instantly.
Python going to be the bottleneck
convert. We're already doing a
non-Python back end.
And like realistically, I honestly am
expecting the um I think that the uh the
Python version of Puffer 4 is going to
be like pretty close in speed to the C++
version, believe it or not, because like
the operations that are have a lot of
overhead are all going to be fused into
single kernels or whatever.
about the same. That's cool.
I don't know. I could jam. Like I think
I probably would not hate Zigg. Um like
obviously I've chosen C for Puffer
because I really don't think Z has the
same level of adoption. If Z were a
super popular language and not just like
currently the trendy hobby language,
I'd consider it. But as for just like
picking the stable universal thing that
is good,
C is kind of the obvious choice.
Picked up quicker than Rust. Well, I'd
hope so for that.
Rust is just like this one does not
bring joy. I hate pretty much everything
about that stupid language.
It's still better than I think it's
still better than like modern C++, but
that's a low bar.
No borrow checker or lifetimes.
Same pattern as freeing. Yeah. See, I
don't know why that's built into the
language either. Like, you should just
be able to like an allocator, an area
allocator takes like 20 lines to write.
Like, it's not a bad pattern, but I
don't know why it's like such a big
selling point. Like this kind of like
reminds me of the people who find it
amazing that you can write a you know
the TS Odin clip where he like writes a
a list or a vector in C and everybody's
like oh you can write lists in C. It's
like yeah how the hell do you think
they're implemented?
Modern C++ no good. Rust better. They
both suck
allocator that works on GP and CUDA. Oh,
actually I do have one question for you
at so the one negative um that I noticed
with doing area allocator style
uh style things is you break a dress
sanitizer, right? So if you have like
each thing has its own allocation then
when you write past the boundary of that
you can catch that with the address
sanitizer. Whereas if you put if you
bunch all of your allocations together
and you write across the boundary of one
thing into the next thing but not out of
the entire block of memory
then you break this sanitizer
or is that handled for you?
N C++ sucks. I have no The only good
thing about C++ is that you can
technically just write C in it. Use the
testing allocator.
It's default and debug. That's not
terrible.
I think it's better to just have the
compiler be the thing that you change to
test your code rather than your code
itself. But it's not bad.
How does that thing work though? I guess
it marks the boundaries every time you
request a piece from it. Yeah, I
actually I could see that working.
That's actually Yeah, that's a good
thing to have built into the language
because then you get area style
allocations, but you don't break your
sanitizer. Yeah, I could see that.
That's fine.
It's slow as [ __ ] Of course, it's slow,
right? The same thing. Um, I'd actually
be interested to see how slow it is
compared to like C's address annotizer,
right? Or I guess not C's, but like
clangs,
right? Cuz yeah, your code gets super
slow, but it builds fast and it's still
plenty fast for testing stuff.
Okay, I've been yapping enough here. Um,
it's been good chatting, but I need to
actually get this stuff done because I
want to get to Tiny today, guys. I want
to also have time to do Tiny stuff
today. And uh, we just have to fix this
end.
Gives you more confidence that compiles
and test pass. It'll run
compiles and test pass.
No, I don't know. I don't mind the um
you know the runtime sanitizer checks
debugging
0.979x
of five boy. I will let you work on that
for a bit. You said 5 mil. I'm not going
to hold you to 5 mil. If you can get 2
mil, I think that's already
I think 2.4 mil would get you 100k SPS
with frame skip.
Everything is still Python resonant. Uh
you do not need to make it
can be bashed 100k if that makes sense.
So like yeah it's the it's the batched
one that has to be so if you're if
you're running like the loop in Python
over each end it can be batched in
groups of I don't know whatever they
used for training.
So it's the vector step I'll talk
that'll take over that'll take a lot of
the overhead like obviously if you're
stepping each end in a Python loop
stream on Monday guys it would be today
if I could shut up and like get this
stuff done but I mean there were some
cool things to look at so not so bad.
Uh,
render down samples.
Uh, you could have your render, you
could have the downsampling built into
this emulator.
That would be fine. In fact, that would
be better.
I actually would believe that there's
you could probably shave a lot of time
off of the rendering with fused down
sample. Like that is something that I
would believe that there's a legitimate
optimization in.
You don't output pixels every step.
You'd still you'd output pixels like
every 24th or whatever.
Poke poked, you do not uh you do not do
pixels every frame. That's not how the
current p uh that's not how the current
implementation works.
If that is how it works, then they're
dumb. Like I do not believe they were
that dumb when they implemented it
though. It only renders every 24th.
You're not going to beat it by much
doing that though. Most of the um most
of the runtime is not the rendering.
It's the it's the states because you're
only rendering every 24th anyways.
You'll be able to make the render step
way faster than Pi Boy. I believe that
Numpai [ __ ] Yeah, that's not the
emulator though, right? That's that's
like that guy's code. Um,
the base emulator is still nowhere near
speed.
Base emulator is only like 1k per core.
So, upper bound would be like 16k
probably.
That's still 2x faster than their
current code. But then there there are
other sources of overhead with it as
well.
Actually, the thing that I'm doing right
now will be a nice little boost
because it'll eliminate some of the copy
overhead.
This is not for Pokemon specifically.
This will just be general purpose
improvement.
What the heck did I screw up here? Um
X send
back streams buffer
right
then and Cstep on N.
Oh, I didn't transfer the OBS, dummy.
Yeah, I didn't transfer the OBS.
I hate that I'm pasting this everywhere,
but for now we will um
Okay, the second I actually pay
attention.
So this is still is this still bad?
This is substantial training, but this
is like this is significant, but this is
still bad.
Honestly, that seems fine to me.
Act size
One
op size is 118 on breakout.
Yeah. 118, not 119.
Correct.
I might have messed something up here.
Honestly,
I kind of did this super quick when I
was tired.
So
what did I do here? Numb buffers times
horizon
have index percent buffers
I divided by num buffers
narrow should never
this should always return a view.
copy in obs batch
copies in action batch
copies
logs
values
rewards terminals
This is nonthreaded though.
What could I have possibly messed up
without even having threading?
Well, this is the
this is the jank one, right?
this is not supposed to break everything
completely.
So, anything above eight is substantial
training for breakout.
Yeah. So, this is
Oh, wait. Did we take a speed hit
without me noticing?
No, the speed hit is from being single
thread.
Actions equals pufferell envactions.
Uh en obs.
Wait.
OBS actions rewards terminals is create
environments.
Create
environments
Okay. So obsessive reward terminals
these are all the GPU values right.
So then this vec gets
that
poke gym is the overhead not the
emulator.
So
that thing does um
poke Jim is and mostly an envrapper
that does a lot of state manipulation to
produce custom obs.
Yeah, that thing is going to have a
bunch of overhead.
But if you're at the 20 whatever
thousand it was single thread, then
you're still roughly matching the pi boy
SPS. And if you assume you can get a 16x
speed up, the fastest you could possibly
get would about be about 16k training,
which is better than what they peak at
like 10k, but it's not like a
generational difference.
Yes. And we have to convert between
Yeah. Um, we have to convert,
but I think that the base the base
emulation speed
like it's still not like it's 10x faster
on the base emulation speed, right?
To give it the exact same. So
ultimately, you don't have to do that,
right? I thought that that would be a
convenient test,
but like you can obviously merge like as
long as you have an obs format at the
end of the day, right? Um the puffer n
format is useful because you can't get
as fast without the puffer n format cuz
that's literally just a vector format
that saves you a copy. I guess you can
just pay the copy overhead. I guess
you're going to have a worse RL
algorithm though if you use custom
framework
unless you've reimplemented the puffer
train algorithm.
You are free to find that out the hard
way.
But the um the RL algorithm is not
something that you can simply just like
do a custom one and have it be as good.
Yeah. So you'd have to port it
evolutionary PO
evolutionary comma. Yeah.
So there's a there is a generational gap
between PO and what we have
and EVO is like yeah that does not work.
I mean, as you can see, this is the
stuff that I'm working on at the moment.
You're closer to clean RL. Uh, I mean,
the style of the code we get as close as
possible, but like clean RL,
we're trying to get um well, no, because
Clean RL doesn't have any of the like
the algorithm that we have, right? Our
algorithm is a bunch of modifications on
top of PO
uh that we've tested on all of our M's
and you know we've made improvements
over the course of time. You also need
the vectorzation method. You need this
exact thing that I'm working on now.
This double buffered vec. Uh you really
can't make stuff fast without that if
you're going to have CPU environments.
Uh, the new thing I'm working on here
will also cut out the transfer overhead.
Oh, yeah. That guy. Was there uh was
there substantial
uh CUDA device overhead with um the
Pokemon experiments?
because the thing I'm working on now
should more or less eliminate that type
of overhead
let it down significantly. Yeah. So what
I'm doing now is instead of just
buffering the uh buffering the end
computations like double buffering that
I'm also buffering the CUDA transfers.
So you'll get OBS not on CPU ready but
you're going to get OBS on GPU ready.
Yeah, emulation is still the biggest
bottleneck.
for Pokemon specifically
that would have to go up an order of
magnitude I think to make that end like
I'd say even usable for modern
algorithms
direct to device. Yeah,
I'm working on some pretty cool tech.
Uh it's going to be like a a couple
million SPS boost at least as well to
the C back end because the C back end
has lower overhead over like the C++
back end has lower overhead everywhere.
So really this is the main source of
overhead
and then there's like CUDA launch stuff
and other things but the main one.
Oh wait is this
KU and 8? Did I mess this up?
I think I might have messed this up,
right?
Wait. K, and 8.
Hang on.
Does copy underscore is this safe? If I
do
write into compiled languages as needed,
not just cuz.
Yeah.
Well, honestly, we're going to have
both. So, the idea is going to be that
I'm it is substantially easier for me to
do the development here. in fact because
I know there is no Python overhead. And
then the idea is that I'm going to have
chunks of this exported as standalone
functions to Python.
So I think that the Python uh ultimately
the Python version is going to get
pretty close to the C++ version, but
it's still going to be good to have this
regardless because like I wouldn't be
able to dev the whole thing in Python.
hard for me to follow what you're doing.
I follow bits of it.
You can ask questions as well.
At the moment, I'm trying to figure out
what I screwed up uh while I was
developing. I like I broke the
vectorzation back end here.
Context thing above.
Was
this literally it?
Wait, seriously?
Still seems broken.
Moving between Python and C
for specific blocks.
Um, no, you're strictly removing
overhead in this case.
There are ways you can do it where you
would incur overhead
the way I'm doing it like no
because basically every every call like
every single line from Python has the C
to Python overhead anyways. You're
strictly removing overhead by batching
them.
software engineering design. You need
more ML. What are you optimizing right
now? So, what I'm optimizing now is we
have a whole bunch of environments. So,
a whole bunch of instances of the thing
that we're training RL on. And I am
writing a backend that multi-threads
uh the execution of several thousand
instances of environments and I'm doing
it in a way such that you can run them
asynchronously
so that by the time you need data from
one set of environments uh it is already
ready for you and the thing I'm doing at
the moment is in this new backend it's
going to be ready for you on the GPU.
So,
it's a whole bunch of like asynchronous
data transfer stuff.
How did you learn CUDA? I didn't. I just
started writing it.
I wrote a bunch of C and then just went
asked. CUDA is just C that runs on your
GPU. How hard could it be?
And for stuff that has like pretty
trivial parallelism, that is kind of
just true. You can kind of just like
write pretend you're writing C and it's
the same thing.
They're floats.
I got to go look at what I had this as
before. Man, I think I messed something
up.
Okay. So I do explicitly transfer
everything to be floats.
Actions copy. This is float 32.
All right, let's see if this fixes it.
That would be kind of funny.
So I basically I don't know if these
copies are actually checking the types
match.
I think that it's possible that this is
what was messed up.
This code's a little bit of a mess
because this is like you don't have
Python's indexing syntax
and all it's doing is copying a bunch of
observations into buffers.
Yeah, this is not training cleanly.
[Music]
They say rewards
clamp.
Oh, hang on.
This very well could be it. If we're not
clamping rewards correctly,
Well, we have a bunch of checking to do.
I want this to not take all day. So, I'm
going to put a time limit on this. Uh,
if I don't solve this by three, so 52
minutes, we'll just go to Tiny Grab. Let
me use the restroom. I'll be right back.
I got to grab myself more coffee and
then we'll keep cranking on this.
We'll keep cranking.
I get so lazy around the holidays.
I have like an instinctive need at the
moment to be drinking hot chocolate and
like playing games and not doing any
work. But then puffer does not get
built. So
instead today we will attempt to get
this thing to work. The Perf test is at
30 mil. If we can actually get that 30
mil then we've pretty much eliminated
all the overhead problems we've ever had
in games. I no longer allow myself to
play the games that I would like to be
playing because that is straight
heroine. Uh I've got stupid number of
hours in two different MMOs. What I've
been doing lately though is this Aaron
Shore. Uh this thing is awesome. This is
a single dev built like a full single
player MMO with scripted bots that
follow you around and fill out your
party. So I've been having fun with
that. And I've also been getting ideas
for neural MMO 4 because once neural MMO
3 is solved, there will be a neural MMO
4. You'd like Factorio but don't because
I like Puffer. Uh, actually very wrong.
I generally do not like that type of
game, Tim.
If I will optimize the crap out of like
gear setups and stuff in MMOs, but the
factory style optimization has not been
my thing.
I played like I played Satisfactory for
a couple weeks and got bored.
Yeah, I've seen um Runescape has gotten
a ton of cool updates in the last couple
of years since I have not played. And as
tempted as I am, I know I cannot
download that game.
Straight heroine.
Actually, both of my favorite games have
gotten like massive updates. They're
both like 20-year-old games, and they've
both gotten massive updates that I know
I would enjoy, but I would not be able
to stop playing for a minimum of two
months straight.
Like, I am absolutely capable of playing
something for 12 hours a day for two
months straight. It's just like complete
reward hacking.
Yeah. Dark Age of Camelot. Oh, that's a
that's a throwback.
One is Guild War II. Nope.
Old school Runescape is one of them.
That one's uh pretty common. And the
other one you only have heard of heard
of if you're in Europe, uh which was
Dophus, which I found on Mini Clip, not
being from Europe. And uh those two are
probably my favorite two games of all
time,
French. Yep. This tactical fantasy chess
on steroids
if it's um any context for the amount of
time on those games. I have an infernal
cape uh and a dusted Omelette on RS.
And I think I've had parties of up to
like six 200s that I would play jointly
on Dophus.
Did I miss that? Honestly,
like Runescape back in the day was not
even that good of a game. I didn't play
that when I was growing up. It's
actually gotten to be a good game in the
past few years
because they basically just kept doing
the old school style of content, but
then they added actual mechanical uh
mechanically interesting stuff into it.
So, it's like they had a okay game and
then they broke it with RS3 and then
they made the old school version and
then they added more stuff to that and
now it's good.
Albian. That's the PVP one, right?
I've only heard of that one because of
the PvP.
Yeah, I really like MMOs.
Part of it is just like the games are
awesome, but it's also like the idea of
a simulated world is just so cool and
interesting to me. Uh that like
progresses over time as the player base
does. And it also happens to be a
stupidly good model for AI. So, I kind
of got everything in one bucket at the
same time like that.
And pretty much all of the low-level
stuff as well from neural MMO, it just
came straight from the exact
implementation of like the runes cape
tick system and stuff.
No data.
What?
I just want to make sure we're updating
the right thing.
I don't never use LMS for anything. I
use them as fuzzy docs. I just don't
like them writing my code.
Generally the only time when I reach for
LLMs to write code it's because like
there isn't a way to even learn how to
do the thing that I want to do and
that's usually a factor of like having
to work around a big clunky systems that
I don't even want to have there in the
first place. Like the torch C++ API is
actually a good example of this because
it's just not documented well at all.
And then trying to get that to play nice
with CUDA is like ah
How did this freaking go?
Oh, wait. No, it's fine.
Okay, so this actually
uh No, I needed to do this. I want to
make sure that this is getting copied
correctly. You see?
Yeah. This is the thing that could be
wrong.
I don't know if silently one of these is
making a copy.
Okay, so state before is zero.
Okay, this is correct. So apparently
narrow never copies,
which it shouldn't.
Uh so why like what the heck else is
broken then?
I'm going to set this num buffers to one
here real quick.
I'm going to try with one buffer and
we're going to see if it still breaks.
Where do you get this ADX faster than Pi
Boy from though is the question.
Yeah. No, you did. This is why you got
me so excited. You did the profiling
wrong, man.
They have it right here in the docs.
The 395 times real time 60k frames. This
gets you pretty close to that 24,000
single thread.
Cuz like if you actually get ADX the
performance of Pi Boy like you will
fundamentally change the whole field of
RL
I
would be so surprised if you can get
that but
okay look at this.
So now we have 300 something score.
But now if I change this to two buffers,
it breaks. Really?
Oh, I wonder if we do actually have
genuine race conditions in here. That'd
be kind of embarrassing, right?
There's no way to like
compile the code of an arbitrary Game
Boy game to run natively on a modern
CPU, right? There's like no reasonable
way to do that.
So, you can run it not with an emulator.
Cuz
like obviously if you reimplemented
Pokemon for a modern CPU it could be way
faster.
There is
so like not even having the emulator
just like
poker full disassembly. Yeah, but it's
disassembled for
for the like the the hardware of like
the original Game Boy hardware, right?
Like you see what I mean, right? If you
wrote if it weren't going through the
emulator
before HLE,
that should be way faster. If you had an
AR, if you had a way to just do that for
any Game Boy game, that would be
I think then you can genuinely get
millions. I will be shocked if you get
an emulator to millions.
Um,
if you do it, you do it and then it just
rocks. And I will be very very happy to
be wrong on that one.
Interesting.
Either I have messed something up here
or I have genuine race [ __ ]
happening.
Wait, I can't have race [ __ ]
happening. This is single threaded.
Uh, okay.
They don't have perf bench FBR. You'd
have to benchmark it. They don't
actually have a benchmark that I can see
here.
They just do like, "Oh, it's very fast."
But like,
watch the training. Yes, Tim. That's
what we're trying to figure out exactly
what is going on with the training.
Buff times block size. Buff times block
size.
And how the heck
why are these results not the same?
Huh?
You do vec receive.
Yes, it blocks, right?
That's the whole point.
It is a pure and empirical science.
You're treating it as not one and you're
doing it wrong as a result.
They should literally be the same
operations, right?
Oh,
I forgot there is an RMS norm.
There any genuine way that it's like it
could just be the RMS norm?
I don't believe it. Right.
Otherwise, the ops are the same except
for that norm.
Why RMS norm is evil.
Wonder if you can just replace um
replace it with like a running norm of
some type.
Can't think of any other possible
explanations.
Ve size over vector buffers.
hypers wouldn't be different. I don't
think so, Tim. Like technically their
RMS norm gets computed.
No, wait. RMS norm is not over batch.
So it is identical. Yeah, it should
literally be identical,
right? RMS norm is over just the hidden
dim. So it's
Yeah, it should literally be identical.
Yeah, I'm think I was thinking of batch
norm. So no, that can't even be the
issue.
and then
we narrow like this.
Logit's value state out. This gets
copied. We double check that this
propagates to state.
You know what happens? I wonder
I wonder if we internally have race.
Hang on.
Python backend solves. What do you mean?
No, no, no. We have a whole bunch of
different things at this point. I try
I'm going to try changing these to
false.
I bet you that they were not getting um
I bet you we're skipping torches cuda
sync mechanism and we're missing a sync.
You're way better off thinking about RL
like in terms of games than you are
thinking about it in terms of um
MDPs.
Is this still not going to solve?
Really?
Could have sworn it would have been
this.
No, it is not.
You'd have to cheat the time axis into
the MDP,
and then that defeats the point of an
MDP.
And even if you do that, then you make
the MDP way, way more general than you
need, and the model becomes too general
to be useful.
If you just sit and think about the
structure, if you think about the
definition of an MDP and then you think
about the structure of a problem that
you would expect given an MDP and then
you look at the structure of an actual
game, you will see that those two have
you thinking about very very different
things.
It's like simultaneously over and under
specified, funny enough.
It's like too general in ways that don't
matter and then it's missing [ __ ] that
does matter.
Not to mention the MDP on its own is
useless and you at least have to go to a
palm DP where you can't even prove
anything anymore anyways.
I'm so surprised that that doesn't work.
I thought that would be it, man.
Oh, you know, I do wonder actually.
Hang on.
problem formulation. Yes, but it's not a
useful problem formulation.
It doesn't actually give you a good
model of the problems. So, if you're
thinking about the problems that you're
looking at in terms of MDPs, you have a
bad formulation.
but the formulation of an MDP mismatches
the formulation of the problems you
actually care about so badly that it
doesn't actually help you to do that.
That's the point.
That's the thing. There isn't a useful
formulism you can write down.
But it's not be just because you don't
like just because the only formulism
that you have is not particularly like
useful. Let me how do I say this? If you
have a formalism
that doesn't match the problems you care
about, but it's the only thing you have,
depending on the mismatch, right, you
can either stick with the thing that is
not a good representation, but is what
you have, or you can abandon it and do
your work a different way. But I found
it way more useful to just abandon the
bad formalism.
You treat RL as more of an empirical
science. It's guided by intuition and
then extensively experimentally
verified,
which is kind of what's been done with
the rest of deep learning, frankly.
But for whatever reason, like the
formalism in RL is every bit as bad, if
not worse than in the rest of deep
learning. But like academics are very
very attached to it and it's [ __ ] It's
useless
and they've held the field back as a
result.
Every bloody paper starting with MDP
formalism is not
it's not just useless. It's actually
actively harmful to how you think about
problems.
What even is an RL problem? Interaction.
Learning through interaction.
That's the whole definition. A problem
where you have to learn through
interaction with an environment.
See, I can come up with a definition
that anybody can understand that
captures the actual thing that matters
to the field in just a few words. That
is a like people will argue with me
about oh but MDP is in the history and
this and that. It doesn't matter. The
point of a definition is that it is
useful for conveying the thing that
you're talking about. Right? So the
useful definition is through
interaction.
Uhoh.
No. Wait. Is this fine?
Do the me copy.
unsigned char
which is
papers that consider MDPs implicitly.
Yes. So you're allowed to do work on
MDPs. That's fine. But like
it's not a good model for the class of
problems that you think about in RL.
Like framing problems as intuitively as
possible as things that you can visually
understand is much more useful for
understanding what you can and cannot
solve. than is the very abstracted
language of MDPs.
There's a reason that we do so many of
these problems as games, right? Games
are very intuitive. Now, there is one
misleading thing which is that, you
know, the agents can't see the graphics
on the screen like you can. If you put a
key over here and a door over here,
that's actually a very hard problem
because it doesn't know what a key is.
But if you like this is a concept that
you can explain to somebody in a
paragraph or two without any
mathematical background
and then once you get that like you kind
of unlock everything.
You see you can actually understand most
of what I think about in RL without any
of that mathematical formalism.
Send over the actions.
Mem copy from GPU
to CPU
device to host
block size action size is one.
The float.
There's geometry to the problem
how they transform
satisfactory
and that can be your goal. Your goal can
be to come up with satisfactory theory.
But all attempts I've seen by people
much more mathematically gifted than I
am have not like have not only failed
but have not even contributed
to the practical advancement of the
field at all.
Whereas on the other hand, I have a very
clear-cut path forward. Like even though
I don't have some sort of grand unifying
theory, I have a very clear p path
forward where I can tell you with
confidence that you know these problems
will be solved now. These problems will
be solved in a year. These problems will
be solved in two years.
I count things as important to the
extent that they let you solve problems.
Right?
So like in my mind, an infrastructure
contribution that makes everything run
10 times faster is just as valuable as
an algorithmic contribution,
right? that improves like asmtoic
performance on some environments.
Well, in other areas, right, the math is
actually very important, right?
Diffusion at least is one notoriously
mathy area of uh of ML.
But like math is a tool. Engineering is
a tool. Science is a toolkit.
Can't just bash every problem you see
with the same tool and expect stuff to
happen.
The reason I've gone so down far down
the engineering route is because it was
the most useful tool for what I wanted
to accomplish.
I wouldn't be bashing my head against RL
doing all this engineering if it weren't
actually working, right? I'd try
something else.
Yeah, I do have the degrees. And the
thing that I like about having the
degrees is that if I say this without
the degrees, you'll have people who do
have them saying, "Oh, well, you're just
a Philistine. You don't like have the
background to appreciate this stuff."
Now, I get to say, "I do." And you're
still wrong.
And by the way, here's your RL that
actually works and is fast. Now,
universal computation targeting all
targets with Zigg.
If you can make stuff fast,
awesome.
I'll be looking at this stuff much more
closely if you beat those perf targets.
dim name index.
And this is fine.
Oh,
wait. Select one and h
So then you get this one narrow
zero.
and rail.
Yeah, Boon. I mean, we could have done
puffer with Zig, but like
there's really not anything. At least so
far. There's nothing really Zigg has
that I'm missing in C that I would want.
C is just such a simple language.
It's just very nice. Obviously, the C++
is garbage, but like that's the reason
there's C++ here is because of Torch.
And at least for now, there's not really
much getting away from torch.
I'm going to spend a few more minutes on
this and then we're going to go to
tinyrad because I'm kind of stuck for
now.
I I honestly does anybody like
I'm not even threading this at this
point. I don't see how this can possibly
not be working.
Why are you trying to replace Cuda
itself?
Well, I mean, when I'm writing CUDA
kernels, I'm pretty much just writing C.
Yes, I don't like the fact that CUDA is
technically C++, but I just don't write
C++.
My solution is coding.
I highly doubt it on this man.
One 92
threads.
M threads
two threads two buffers
right
M's
Action type is not an int though, is it?
Wait.
Action type
the float.
So I mean the thing I fundamentally
don't understand you see this is getting
like in the 20s.
Okay. So if I just do
I'm going to say we're going to create
this end with one buffer instead of two.
And then I'm going to say that we're
going to do
one buffer here instead of two.
quite confident because simulation is
already used in several areas of
science, right? Very heavily.
Simulation is already the tool that
people rely on. And this makes
simulation a much more powerful tool
because instead of using it to see what
happens, right?
Like simulation ask lets you ask the
question what happens if if I set up
these conditions and run, right? So RL
lets you say how do I get to this point
in the simulation.
Save states for poker. Yes,
and actually the uh the puffer five
plans have to do with save states
in general
to get puffer four done first.
Okay, you guys see this?
Look, it immediately starts learning,
right?
And yeah, there's some janky stuff going
on.
uh overall. But at least this
immediately starts learning
Peters.
Yeah, you'd think so. But actually I
think that the major breakthrough uh the
next major breakthrough of AI is going
to revolve around save states.
It'll be it'll get explained with Per 5.
That's like another probably eight
months away though.
It's going to be more than efficiency
man. And it's going to be an asmtoic
improvement.
And this is telling us that literally
the exact same ops.
The only thing that possibly changes is
these indexing ops and the ve back end.
Right?
Then the vec back end
we have reset that just resets
everything.
These transfers are all
synchronous.
I see nothing that can possibly be wrong
here.
Physics already heavily uses simulation
and research.
It works
on one buffer.
It breaks on two buffers.
His ops are synchronous.
These are your clues.
I just do not see anything that could
possibly
be different. It can't be any
of the D types.
I just changed literally all of the
operations to be blocking
so screwy. I got to get off of this and
do tiny grad. It's like this is going to
drive me nuts.
I'm going to have to I'm going to know
that I'm going to have to do this on
Sunday, which sucks. Or on Monday.
Two buffers versus one work. When
passing to model,
the model goes through half the data,
computes actions. Actions get
transferred.
Those items get stepped. It grabs
observes
them. I'm doing everything synchronous
right now to debug and it's still not
working.
I figured it would be.
Let me just make sure.
I just want to make absolutely sure it's
not some [ __ ] async thing.
So, being mean as a reviewer is not bad.
Gatekeeping useful work for [ __ ]
reasons is bad.
Yeah. So, even with two device
synchronizes here,
this is still [ __ ]
Look, as a reviewer, you can write,
"Hey, this paper is garbage." Like,
"What the [ __ ] are you doing?" And like,
I will not that will not earn you my
condemnation. The only thing that earns
you my condemnation is being an
imbecile,
you know?
People
have like the wrong idea as to the point
of review and publishing.
Like the most important things are like
is this technically correct and is this
framing of this misleading.
If both of those are correct, then like
publish whatever
Like honestly, you can already chuck
most of the papers if you just like if
they say, "Oh, but you know, you need to
be harsh because like we have too many
papers." Well, if you just throw out the
papers that are actually wrong
or misleading, you have plenty of room
for to accept papers.
Framing is always misleading. Exactly.
because the review system doesn't punish
you for framing your paper in a way
that's completely misleading.
In fact, it incentivizes you to do so.
Have to get rid of your April Fool's
paper. Look, that's an exception. You're
allowed to submit April Fool's papers.
Wait, did I even do anything? Did I even
do anything misleading on my April's
Fool's paper? Dude, that paper was
actually correct.
I'd be surprised but not astounded if
GPU
uh GPU
GBA emulator works.
256 branching.
That's still a lot.
That's per instruction.
Is it fast? Well, you said it was 80x
faster than pi boy before and it was
about the same speed. So, is it doesn't
even have to be 80x faster, man. You
make it 10x faster than pi boy, it'll be
a big deal.
Well, frame skip obviously is going to
make it slower because like
you have to actually compute those.
Well, you don't have to compute the
states into obs, I guess.
So, there is some stuff you can prune
probably.
Is that a harness
This is just I know I said I was going
to do tiny grad and I need to. This is
just driving me nuts though cuz I cannot
figure out why this is happening.
Like how is this happening like this,
right?
We will do tiny grad. I'll stop at 30.
Give me eight minutes. Test a couple
last things.
Just
Is that on one thread or is that with
the all the threads?
Yeah, this is correct block size. Damn
it.
If that's with all the threads, that's
about pi boy
This is the weirdest thing to me.
I'm trying to think like where even like
sources of error could be that I haven't
considered.
rendering all four with the ray. Oh,
probably shouldn't be doing that.
I mean, I can't see where it wouldn't
be, man. If I set it with one buffer, it
works. With two buffers, it doesn't. I
just do buffer is going to be I percent
and then I over two.
So this is the time and then this is the
buffer.
state batch gets this copy,
right?
Everything gets copied into obs buffer
act buffer log prop buffer
which is what I said right like with the
current speed 16k cap
It's cool for sure. Hey, don't get me
wrong, it's definitely cool. But you did
kind of start this thing with saying
that you'd gotten it to be like 80x
faster. So, you got me all excited about
what would literally be a generational
leap that would let us do a ton of new
RL research.
Let's see. You get your 10x would be
good. 10x I think would be good enough.
We'd be able to use these M for like um
we wouldn't be able to use them in like
our standard research, but we'd be able
to use them as like hard evals.
Um
ADX we would be able to use them
in pretty much standard everything.
Yeah, ADX we would definitely be able to
use them.
I don't think there's that much PF in
the chip to squeeze out though without
going to um native.
All right. What's your favorite LLM?
him. We'll do the meme just in case the
meme works.
I don't want to I don't want this thing
in my freaking code base.
this on it.
Okay, so I don't have this on here. Let
me at least see.
I'm pretty sure this thing is entirely
wrong.
layers batch size hidden size. Right.
layers. Batch size
Yeah. No, this thing is completely
wrong.
I actually didn't even expect it to be
that wrong.
Let me make sure I'm not just missing
something. But no, cuz we're taking
every other step, right?
So, this is going to update the first
half of the state.
And we check that this propagates
correctly.
here. I'm going to commit this. If
anybody wants to figure this out, feel
free. But I'm going to do tiny grad
stuff.
That's kind of disappointing. I couldn't
figure this out. Like, we got the perf.
We got the uh the perf to be good, but
um I couldn't figure out this one bug.
Um,
I don't know if I would do your own
thread pool. I guess you can do that for
now, man. But like
unless you're implementing this exact
architecture, it's going to end up being
slower.
I just bind it to Puffer's ve for now.
Like this thing is going to end up being
way faster than whatever thread pool.
Not at those speeds. It's not.
You need buffering.
The vec architecture is the thing that
probably I've spent more time on than
anybody in the world for RL.
Like let me think probably like the vec
architecture and then like the
like env optimization stuff. These are
probably the areas I've spent more time
on than anybody.
Obviously, the threading stuff I'm doing
today is looking completely [ __ ]
stupid because I haven't had to even do
threading. I did it with
multiprocessing, but even then, like the
multipprocessing and puffer is very low
overhead. Like the the main PF is not
even going to be from going from
multipprocessing to threading or Python
to C here. The main improvement that
we're going to get is going to be from
buffering the uh the GPU transfers.
got to love when the people that are
haters are just [ __ ] idiots.
It's one of my favorite things. It's
actually I think I'm way more happier
when uh I'm way happier when I have like
critics that are utterly stupid than
when I have no critics.
Cuz when you have no critics, it's like,
okay, echo chamber. When you have
critics, but they're obviously idiots.
Way better.
83k
with Raleb. 83k good. 83k would actually
be very good.
Okay,
I will have to see what you're doing.
I'm going to let you keep cooking on
this for a bit. Let me use a restroom
real quick. I pushed this stuff. So, if
anybody wants to help me figure out what
I've screwed up with double buffering
code is there, build vec and then um
setup.py appi build x uh build torch in
place force
and um there are just two places where I
have it hardcoded to one buffer or two
on create environments
but I can't figure out why it only works
with one buffer fully synchronous no
threading it's very odd
discord
You do still have to add frame skip
though.
So, the exact setup it's um you it's you
render every 24th frame
at the moment.
And if it's not clear why you do that,
it's because Pokemon does not have
control that matters on the order of
every frame.
Like, so if you just take actions every
24 frames, that's how long it takes you
to walk a tile. So like, there's no
point of processing data any faster than
that. You're just throwing away compute.
This is with frame skip.
So this is rendering every 24th frame.
What did you do that got it from um
like 15k to 80k then
you don't have that many threads on here
like you don't have that many cores
you made some architectural ch parallel
I thought you didn't have it running you
didn't say that you had it rendering at
But you didn't say that you had it
rendering that fast before.
You had it at 24K.
You had it at 24K without rendering,
right? 24K per core, which with frame
skip is 1K.
So, how on earth did it get from like
that's more than a multiple of 32?
And you also set more workers than you
have. Of course,
you have 64 workers on.
Is this a different CPU?
No. No, this is the same. Okay.
1. Yeah, but you shouldn't be
a single core. Yes, but one times you
had 1,000
times
I thought it was you had 20 something K
with no rendering, didn't you?
Which is with frame skip should be 1,000
per core.
So, how on earth did you get better than
linear speed up? Like 3x better than
linear speed up?
Especially since if this is the same CPU
as before, that CPU architecture only
has eight good cores in it. It has eight
P cores and 16 E cores. We have those
exact machines back here. And that
architecture is kind of a pain in the
ass. Like, you never get more than a 16x
out of it. Skipping is faster, not
slower.
Oh, wait. Are you counting?
I I
Wait. You have to still step the state
though. You can't skip the state
updates.
So, you get one. You get 24x less data.
We're rendering all 60 FPS. I'm so
confused.
You have your FPS number wrong. Like the
way that you should be calculating
the FPS, it's by the number of rendered
frames, but you're only rendering every
24th frame.
So, is this is this multiplied by 24?
Are you counting the number of states
here? Are you counting the number of
rendered frames?
Because if you're counting the number of
states then this is like half or a third
of this beat is pi boy.
We don't step the ppu at all.
We don't step.
All right. So,
but like SPS, so when you count SPS and
RL, okay, I guess it depends cuz people
do it both ways to be fair, but the
comparison to Poke RL was the number of
rendered frames and you only render
every 24th frame.
For frame skip, we don't step the PPU at
all.
Yeah.
But like are you you're counting SPS
with 24? Okay. So then the number of
rendered frames is this divided by 24,
right?
So this is the number of game ticks
total that you're rendering basically.
But then um
the number of rendered frames is 124th
of this isn't.
If that's how you've reported it, then
this is between half and a third of the
speed of pi boy.
because it's there's a metrics reporting
difference. You're quantifying something
in a way that is different from the way
that we were quantifying. No, no, we
don't want you to render all 24 art.
That's not the point. The point is that
this SPS metric gets divided by 24. So,
we're counting the number. We're
counting. So, we are counting the number
of examples that are actually used
during training. You're only using the
frames during training, right? You're
not using the things that are skipped.
you're skipping because there's no
reason to train at that fine grain of a
time resolution when Pokemon doesn't
have control actions at that that low of
a resolution or at that fine of a
granularity rather. Um so the number of
frames that you would train on would be
this divided by 24.
You can define it either way, but at the
end of the day, the thing that really
matters is like the amount of real- time
game data that you're training on. So if
you want another way to look at it, it's
speed up over real time would be one.
You can define it either way, but like
the point is you're defining it
inconsistently with how we had it
defined. And then like you I think
you're comparing that your 24x higher
metric to
uh the one like the one that we have
which is dividing.
You know if I were to convert to your
metric it would be let me think. I think
we got up to like 8,000 steps per
secondish training if I recall. Oh yeah
192k with your number there.
previous screenshot that was without
frame skipping and without
parallelization. What?
I'm not cheating you on metrics here.
I'm just trying to make sure the uh
Oh, okay. So, he just loaded the
website, saw the random demo, and
thought I was a [ __ ] Fair play.
You care about I don't care about
pixels. Otark, here, let me let me
explain to you the thing that I care
about, and let me explain to you why it
is the correct thing to care about.
Okay? I don't care whether you train on
pixels or not. That doesn't matter. Um,
but however you do it,
the agent doesn't need to take a step
every time the game ticks. And the
reason for that, right, is that if the
game is made to run like 60 frames per
second, the control of Pokemon is not
that precise. You would use that level
of control for like a fastflying drone
or something. Like Pokemon really only
needs a couple of button inputs per
second maximum. And it just so happens
that if you run one tile, one tile takes
24 frames to run. So a skip of 24 steps
gets you control at this precision of
one tile.
So whether or not you render, it doesn't
really make sense to take actions more
frequently than every 24 frames.
Yes, you have to step every tick, but
you're only going to use
124th of those steps for training data.
So you can calculate the metric either
way and it's done either way. But as for
the practical of training, if you're
going to compare apples to apples on
speed,
it's like the amount. It's basically how
fast you can run the environment versus
real time if you think about it, right?
So, like here with Pi Boy, it says on an
8 core machine, you could potentially do
3,000 hours of gameplay in one hour,
which sounds like a lot of data until
you see that on neural MMO 3, like we do
in a few days, we do 12,000 years worth
of gameplay.
So, like compared to the other
environments we have, the delta in real
time equivalent speed is still two
orders of magnitude off. And if you were
to bring it up to one order of magnitude
off, then we could basically start using
it for uh more complex tests and stuff.
I'm implementing as a frame skip at the
emulator if it would be so it would be
24 times faster if I did that
frame skip at the emulator. You still
have to do the operations, right?
like the game still has to advance its
state because like once you press the
button once to walk the emulator it
still has to up update 24 times.
Now I don't know if pi boy like spends a
bunch of time computing observation data
or something and there's something that
you can prune
but like that's what you'd like to get.
Does that make sense though? Like I'm
not trying to cheat you on metrics here
or anything. It's just straight up like
you need to run a lot a lot of hours, a
lot of days, a lot of years worth of
games. Um, and you can define the metric
either way,
but like right now there's still this
gap.
Don't update accept every 24th. Yes. So
that's fine.
I mean, you can easily compute this
number, right? which is the real time.
You can easily compute that as well.
That one would give you a comparison.
So, so frame skip is a little bit of
overhead. You can see here 344x real
time with frame skip 15 because
rendering is really expensive, but if
you're only doing it every 15th step,
it's not a huge perf penalty. So, when
you're doing frame skip 24, like the
idea is it shouldn't be that big of a
penalty over over the sim. And you're
mostly constrained by how fast the
emulator is running here, right?
Okay, let me use the restroom and then
we're going to do some tiny grad.
I think I I think I've made it clear.
Hopefully.
right, I need bread time.
Enough fiddling with this stuff. If I
feel like it, I might later tonight. I
might come back to the uh the other
thing. Just Tim, if either of you wants
to fix it, by all means, but I got to
start on some Tiny Grad stuff.
Red useful. That's what we're going to
figure out right now or we're going to
start on. I enjoyed what I saw of it so
far.
Uh where which machine did I do this on?
That's tiny. Yeah, it's right there.
Right. I think I was doing uh torch
mangru and tiny grad men. Right.
Okay, this is not running the full
network yet, is it?
Oh, I'd forgotten that I'd actually had
this get to this point. Cool.
So
Train stop.
This is with beam.
Okay. So without being super slow,
right?
Now the question is why is this slower
than uh PyTorch?
And actually what are we competing
against here? Is this with compiler? Is
this eager mode?
Uh this is literally torch eager mode,
right?
Yeah.
So, it is actually
it's on GPU by default.
That's actually kind of funny that they
do that.
What would be the possible benefits?
Um, allow me to show you.
Where is it?
Well, I posted.
So, I there's one of these posts that um
replied to
this one.
Damn it.
I made this post about having to fuse a
bunch of models. He said, "Hey, have you
tried tin? It's very optimized for small
models." I said, "I haven't because of
this." And he says,
"Uh, I'm fusing tons of small kernels.
Tiny will literally do that for you." I
said, "Okay, I'll be surprised if this
gets close to purse to Perf." Um,
if I spend a little time to benchmark
and post publicly, will you take a quick
look and tell me if I'm doing the Tiny
one stupidly? He says, "Sure."
Uh, written correctly and with Beam,
Tiny should outperform all but the best
handwritten kernels.
So, basically, he says, "Hey, I think
that this will be fast for small
models." Uh, and he's offered to check
once I run some Perf tests. So worst
case scenario, you know, I say, "Hey, I
tried this. Take a look." And he says,
"Yeah, this Perf test is right. Uh, I
guess it doesn't work because this,
this, and that. No harm done." Then I
just know even more so that I'm building
Puffer the correct way and there are no
viable alternatives, right? Um, best
case, we find something useful perfwise
where we can like use some of their
kernels or something, right?
Oh yeah, where's the profiling stuff? I
had a whole bunch of tiny grad people.
Actually, let me just tweet this.
Yeah, that's the idea behind this. Um,
where is their profiling stuff?
one kernel on the GPU.
large concrete graph into subgraphs that
fit in a kernel
Oops. This is tiny grads. Neural net
file
is not that long.
350 lines.
They actually do not have that many ops.
And they just so happen to have most of
the ops that I would like.
It's very succinct. I'll give them that.
The question is if it's fast
their back end
correctly written in with beam should
outperform all but the best handwritten
chromes. Okay, so where do they have
their
tiny profile
profile?
I was told there's like a little web
thing or whatever.
Biz equals 1.
developer docs,
bunch of tutorials,
developer docs.
Okay.
can easily we can easily pry under the
hood
to see how this computation occurred.
Okay, so you literally just run debug
equals 2. Cool. debug equals 2.
Uh yeah, that's too much profiling, my
guy. Let's see what this gave us.
Oh, okay.
Cuz this gives us
How does that still give us a billion
things
point?
because I'm not running the right thing
apparently.
That's torchman grew dummy.
Four main rows in the output.
The first two empty refers to the
variable A and B.
debug equals 4 gets you oh gets you the
GPU code. Whoa, that's actually really
cool. So I can just get that and paste
it basically.
Okay.
Um, it would be nice if this got us
readable code,
but let me see what we're getting here
because this is actually very cool.
Copy
NV Python.
But then this is not going to give us
how do you profile like the uh the
optimized version.
Oh, yay. Now we have tiny grad people
here. Running with viz equals run should
open in a web browser with debug as
well.
So, we have a ton of ops here.
Um,
we have, yeah, a ton of operations.
Yo, Azie. Um, so I just profiled one one
operation.
If I want to get a profile like you know
in torch I would run profile and I would
average over a ton of I'd average over
several iterations and it would
accumulate results across
uh runs of the same kernel. Is there a
way to do that here? because I want to
basically see where like how efficient
tiny is compared to torch and compare
stuff like you know copy times um launch
times actual kernel time stuff like that
also why is this not like part of the
docks
or is It
is it literally just in the flags?
very top there is a profile
here.
Oh,
okay. So, what should I do then?
Yay. We have summed we have summoned the
tiny users. So, how should I do this?
So, I just did like onestep profile
here. Uh there's a warm-up here and then
I do the main thing like this.
So how should I do this so I can get an
aggregated profile? Oh,
So, this is now going to spam a ton of
stuff.
Oh, does it aggregate it for you by
default? Am I just dumb?
okay. It seems like it does aggregate
it, but I don't think it excludes the
warm-up, does it?
We got this funky graph
which is presumably somehow my network.
Why you do ML and AI and C and not on
Python? I have both.
You can't write the M's in Python.
If you're doing reinforcement learning
M's in Python, you're doing it slow.
Like slow by a factor of 100 or a
thousand.
All right. How am I supposed to use this
thing
I'm just trying to figure out like how I
um
how am I supposed to use this data?
I don't get like uh it doesn't show me
how much time is being spent in each
kernel, right?
Okay. View input graph.
Number the U ops.
Earliest rewrites.
Where do you learn to do the C part?
I just started doing it.
Um,
it turns out it's just low-level dev is
much easier and more fun than you would
expect.
I'm honestly at this point I'm way
happier when I get to write C than
writing Python.
See, it's just so simple and easy.
Run rangeify
reduced collapse. I don't know what this
is.
First view tag to rangeify
split kernels
I think that this is because I don't
know why there are this many of them
though.
I mean, we do have like a four layer
stacked mining grew. So, presumably this
is that pattern.
You have a starting point. Yes, I have
uh I've got educational material on my X
right here.
These two articles have all of my best
advice on general programming in ML as
well as on how to get into RL.
like what am I supposed to do with this?
This is a very pretty graph.
But like what am and this is like very
nice and smooth as well. So good job on
that. But what am I supposed to do with
this
final trim step in the profiler? It
should give you timings of each kernel.
Okay. So
I see. So you can do like this, right?
I don't know why I didn't try that.
So is it this this thing
batched 14
how did the program is split into
kernels and how they op they're then
optimized right but like the main thing
that I would want is timings
right
like I would like to know
how much time is being spent in copies
how much time is being spent in you
So this has just dumped a ton of data
here, right? But then it's not
aggregated over batches for me.
So this is batched 14.
Four, five.
I think this gives me this does give me
the kernel breakdowns kind of.
Of course, they're not like named in any
way that I can make use of.
I see there are some smaller ones in
there as well.
How do you make use of chat GPT? Uh the
two I generally do not like using LMS to
write large chunks of code. Um with some
small exceptions. Uh the main things I
use, I have Super Maven, which is just
like a oneline really stupid fast model
for autocomplete. I basically use it as
a better LSP and then I will also use
whatever latest model I feel like as a
fuzzy documentation.
And
I you I always get a model that has
that's like fast and responsive. I'm
never going to be sitting there waiting
two minutes for a freaking model.
Maybe if you beam and just do one step.
Okay, I can do that because it should be
cached anyways, right? But I thought it
needs Does it not need uh It should need
a warm-up even with beam, right? Don't
you have to warm up the kernel?
I don't think one step is going to give
us a good profile.
Like this is kind of a dumb way to like
this is kind of a dumb way to profile
stuff, right?
Like okay this gives us something simple
but
like this is not aggregated in a useful
way.
compiler or Yeah, I still don't know
what this is, man.
Yeah, you can't just zoom in on one.
Like, that's not how you should be doing
stuff, right?
You need this to be
Oh, George
aggregations implemented. Well, they
have to be doing something cuz they're
profiling their code somehow, right?
Like they have all this stuff on Perf.
Unless they're doing everything super
manually.
What are these giant gaps between these
calls?
The near gello.
This looks like a network. What are
these gigantic gaps between calls?
Jet capturing
scheduled 28 kernels scheduled 14
kernels.
Okay. Jet captured 14 kernels with one
inputs.
Jet graph batching 14 kernels.
Okay. So, what are these numbers?
I think this is what the the profile
thing should tell us, right?
Uh where was it? I lost where I was in
the docks.
Uh, your page is white and that hurts my
eyes.
Okay. So
four main columns
So what is this?
What are these numbers?
This doesn't have a header on the table.
Okay. Okay. So, they don't even have a
freaking
maple.
This is not what we need.
I think this would be valuable feedback
for Gio. I'm streaming all of it. I'll
at him with some of it,
but I'd like to put in at least some
amount of effort before I start bugging
him on this. Like, does anybody
understand?
So, first of all, what Okay, what are
these? First of all, what is this
number? And what is this number?
Like this is this like launch and
like it the table doesn't have a
freaking header on it, man. The table
should have a header on it.
Actually, I'm going to start up
a little dock.
RL to model human reasoning.
I don't know. There's some stuff you can
do, but it's definitely not guaranteed
to match one to one in the slightest.
Welcome everyone on YouTube. I'm
currently trying to figure out um we
were doing some optimization on the new
vector back end earlier today and now I
am back to evaluating tiny.
Oh wait, does it say here
25 microsconds and the total elapse time
is now at
0.03.
Okay, so this one here,
this is the total time in the program so
far
and this is how long the op took.
Okay,
so
we have aside from I don't know what
happened right here.
Yeah, we're occasionally getting these
spikes
where it takes forever,
but then most of the time we have 200
micros,
And then this goes up to a thousand.
Does it?
Hang on. Let me
is 1024. So it's doing a,000 iterations
and it is saying that this are
200 microsconds is actually
tiny.
Wait, that's really good, isn't it? Hang
on.
Numb layers batch is 4096, right?
How what is the SPS of that?
So wait 4096
um times
two if I say 200 microsconds
that is 0.2 two milliseconds, right?
I believe so. So, point
that would be 1 ms. So, O2 is that it
yeah, which gives us our 20 million
steps. That gets us like 20 million
steps per second,
which is actually what we would expect,
right? Because this is what would match
torch. So, it's actually almost torch
speed except that randomly we have some
of these are slow.
So, actually this matches torch except
that randomly some of these are slow.
So, let's see if I've done something
stupid.
Oh, you know what I've done stupid?
I know exactly what I've done stupid.
I forgot the no grad.
That's still there.
But is that way better?
That seems way better.
yeah. So that's annoying. So even
without without this training on right,
we're still at 16.82 mil which is
underperforming.
Tiny does that by default.
So
yeah, like some of these are just
randomly slow.
I guess we don't see it for torch
though. Oh, it could be cuz torch
profiles in a very different way.
Well, I like how it gives us g flops.
This is really nice.
What is this? Mem
argu one. Mem. Okay. Em.
Oh, and then this is the uh the SPS with
the profile on goes down to 13, which is
not terrible.
Now, that doesn't get me the same info.
Oh,
Okay, so
here are ops.
Uh,
that's a lot of time between ops.
And then
micros. Micros.
Are these actually very consistent?
Let's see.
Oh, these are very consistent, aren't
they?
Yeah. Yeah. Look, the actual ops are
super consistent. And then there's just
randomly these big gaps.
Yeah. So, Tiny just randomly does this.
Yeah, that looks like a decent chunk of
PF.
You're missing.
Why does it do this
graph rewrite? But these are all over
the place and these are tiny
batched.
You see anything else?
Oh, really?
Yeah, I already have that dude.
Wait, llvm. I have context
Should it be cont? Should it be that?
Did you get that from an LM?
and not import. All right, my dude.
It's not that I'm too stupid to like
paste [ __ ] into an LLM. It's that I'm
not so stupid as to just pay [ __ ] into
an LLM.
You don't have to like let me Google
that for you on me with like broken
info.
like the thing that I want to do.
I want to get like a breakdown of
overhead.
Biz equals 1 will cause tiny to save all
pattern matching history and start a web
server script upon exit.
So, okay, you can actually just go look
at the kernels and the code. That's very
nice. But that's not what I meant by
profiling in this case.
Like this is a very very useful tool for
um looking at generated kernels.
But
operator fusion
nonGPU. This is terrifying.
Um,
I guess you can always just try with and
without jet, but that's terrifying.
[Music]
holds on to all buffers.
Oh, this is fine.
Those buffer
I like that they go straight to the
profiling here,
but I think they're missing
Yeah, they're just they're missing
aggregation over these kernels. I don't
know why they wouldn't have that. That's
like the first thing I would think to
That's the first thing I would think to
do would be to do like aggregate
profile.
See, can I figure out what this is? This
is buffer
kernel.
Well, I mean I
I should do one iteration if I want to
do it this way,
but if I want to see the profiler, then
I can't do that, right?
If I just click on one of these
batch 14.
So I mean I can see all the kernels
here.
What is what is this in the middle?
Right. So, first of all, there goes
a good chunk of overhead
between these two.
let me try something simpler to start
with, guys, so I can just get one thing
done for sure today. Uh, well, I got 10
15 minutes and then I got dinner. But I
think I'm going to do an evening stream
tonight.
Test
tiny grad.
Py test tiny grad
snorm.py. Hi.
I think they even have an RMS form in
here, don't they?
Uh, and they have RMSORM.
dim
apps.
Oh, it's probably the realize on
everything. That's probably doing a cuda
sync.
Okay, that's my bad.
Oh, that's actually majorly my bad,
isn't it?
It's going to cheat if I don't, isn't
it?
Forward. Realize.
Uh, no, I didn't do realize, so we're
good.
Okay. I thought I'd messed it up. I was
going to be embarrassed, but no, we
don't need discount flops.
Okay, so this is 73 mil.
And then let's do the exact same thing.
Oh yeah, and since I'm going to have to
go in a few for everybody watching, um I
stream pretty much all my dev. And if
you're interested in that, everything's
at puffer.ai. You can help me for
absolutely free by feeding the puffer
star on GitHub. Uh, if you want to get
involved with dev, Discord is here.
discord g/puffer. You can follow me on X
for all sorts of educational and
research content as well as occasional
other things, but mostly on topic
Okay.
Uh that is
that is actually good. You see that? So
tiny just generated us a
2x faster kernel
than uh
Will it cheat if I don't realize?
Hang on.
these tensions. I think you do need
realize, don't you?
Any tiny users? Do I need realize for
fair comparison? like or is it going to
skip this entire loop or am I good?
What did the colonels get called?
Uh, good point.
okay. So it looks like this
with uh
this version.
If I don't call realize
and I do the same thing,
without realize you aren't doing any
matt moles.
So I I'm a little confused then because
what's it doing if it's cheating? It
should be way faster.
So without realize I get 102 mil
and with realize I'm just making sure I
don't want it to be doing like an extra
CUDA sync, right?
86 mil. There's some variance. Oh, wait.
There's a lot of variance. Never mind.
Hang on. Maybe it's the same speed.
Oh, there's a lot of variance. Never
mind.
Uh, no, wait.
It's slower now without realize.
So with realize we get um
without realize
106. Okay, same thing. Yeah, same thing.
Doesn't matter.
It's got to be running the computation,
man. And it's the same speed with or
without it.
Well, that's actually good, isn't it?
Because look.
Oops.
I think we can use at least these
kernels either way.
I'll not app them until I have more
comprehensive results.
Cool. I got to run it for dinner in a
minute here. Um, that is a nice result
though. That is a very nice result.
Okay. So, when I use the full tiny grad,
um, unless I'm doing something massively
wrong, the initial conclusion is it's
not like magically way faster than
torch. I still see huge amounts of
launch overhead, but it seems like uh we
can use this for specific kernels
and this might actually generate us some
reasonable stuff. So, I think the next
step for me is going to be to profile
this versus torch versus my custom
kernels for some ops and we will see
what that uh what that gets us. I
actually I think after dinner, guys,
I'll be back on and I'm going to I'm
going to profile the fuse scan operation
versus my implementation because that's
the kernel I spent the most time on. So,
we'll see if Tiny Grad beats torch and
if Tiny Grad beat beats my fuse scan
implementation.
That'll be pretty cool.
The beam or something might enforce the
realize.
Yeah, I don't know why. But regardless,
like this RMS norm op is a pain in the
ass. And uh it looks like at the very
least, right, this is making it like
three times faster. So that gets me plus
600,000 steps per second to training
just with that one kernel. So if I
export this kernel to CUDA and I bind
this to torch like even without fusing
more stuff to it which I can easily do
that's already useful.
Uh the one thing that I think is a
little awkward is I this is going to
export me size specific kernels.
So I don't know what to do about that.
I have to figure that out
cuz like I need a kernel that I can run
on whatever size input.
Hey Jess, I'm about to go to dinner.
I'll be doing a stream later in the
evening. We fought vectorization for a
long time. It's fast, but there are some
bugs with the buffered version. Uh I'm
working on that. Uh, we started on Tiny
Grad stuff there. We got through some
profiling. It looks like there's some
usable stuff, but not fully done. And I
got to go to dinner now. So, thank you
folks. Star the puffer on GitHub. See
you in an hour.